Ist das ein alt Jungfrei, was ihr hier spielt? Das sind wir ja noch vor zehn. Ne, jetzt ja nicht mehr. Ich bin Fritz, der Chaos Computer Club und schon die sagen hallo, herzlich willkommen zum einmonatlichen Chaos Radio.
Ist das hier an? Ah ja, das ist an.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich höre mich nicht. Da ist unten ein lautstarker Regler.
Ah, jetzt höre ich mich schon besser. Ich höre mich nicht zu der Musik.
Ach Tim, du hörst sie doch eh genug.
Schon immer so?
Ich meine sonst.
Hörst du dich jetzt? Ja, ich kann mich jetzt hervorragend hören, das ist alles wunderbar. Ich mache euch jetzt mal eine Einführung. Kalter Kaffee im Netz. Java und ActiveX geben sich die Kante im Internet und beide versprechen einem das Blaue vom Himmel. Alles wird einfacher, besser, toller und schöner. Der Kaffee-Clutch im Netz erschlägt die elektronischen Diskussionsforen und man hat den Eindruck, dass die Zukunft der Welt davon abhinge. Gar nicht so abwegig. Sun, Netscape, Apple, Oracle und andere Software-Multis führen mit Java den Kampf gegen das Microsoft-Shop Monopol. Die Firma aus Redmond kontrolliert mit ihrem Produkt Windows den wichtigsten Teil der Computertechnologie überhaupt. Die Plattform für Anwendung. An Microsoft vorbei kann derzeit kaum jemand eine Technologie etablieren, weil der Times-Auflagen-Aufkäufer William III überall mitspielen will und spielt. Und die anderen Kinder dürfen nicht mitspielen. Mit Java allerdings scheint der Rest der Industrie das Zauberwort gefunden zu haben, um den Software-Giganten zumindest etwas Paroli zu bieten. Chaosradio brüht euch den Netscafé frisch auf. Wir diskutieren über die Technologien, ihre Vor- und Nachteile und zeigen auch, was dran ist. Am Hype, um warum Java eben mehr als nur eine Programmiersprache ist.
Chaosradio bei Fritz, der Computerplumon, hier bei uns mit dem Chaos Computer Club und natürlich auch wieder mit einigen Möglichkeiten einzugreifen für euch, nicht nur über Telefon. Nachher, wir reden über Java, ActiveX und einige andere interessante Geschichten, was das betrifft. Wir haben heute eine absolute Premiere vor ungefähr einer Stunde, hat Lust, Schramm, nämlich den ersten Chat im fritz www freigegeben zum Testen. Das ist eine Beta-Version, aber ihr könnt dabei sein. Also wir sagen so schön, fire up your browsers und besucht uns hier im www. fritz.de slash speakers slash chats, also Unterverzeichnisse bei fritz.de, Speakers wie die Sprecher, SPE, AK, ERS, slash, Chats wie der Chat und alles weitere seht ihr dann da schon. Ihr müsst euch einen Namen geben und ich hab das hier auf dem Bildschirm. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich viel Zeit haben werde, mit euch zu quatschen, aber da können wir zumindest diesen neuen Fritz-Bereich, der noch nicht offiziell freigeben ist, mal testen. Beta-Version sozusagen. Ansonsten wie immer E-Mail hier chaos.orb.de und warum Chaos? Weil der Chaos Computer Club hier sitzt. Tach. Tach. Tach. Wir sind alle super drauf heute. Spannung, den haben wir heute hier. Letzte Sendung war ja doch völlig andere Besetzung. Hat sich von euch keiner getraut. Aus Technologien übrigens eine Sendung, die sehr viel Feedback hatte. Also ich war da. Du warst da, ja das stimmt. Andreas war da, aber was war mit euch?
Ja, wir sind aus dem Westen und wir wollten alle mal das Maul halten, weil wir das wieso keine Ahnung von haben.
Habt ihr es gehört?
Ich habe es in Teilen leider nicht ganz hören können, aber ich fand es eigentlich recht amüsant und recht informativ. Vor allem war ich sehr überrascht von der Vielzahl von Hörern, die also wirklich sehr grundlegende Dinge zu berichten wussten.
Ich fand es auch äußerst interessant. Vor allem war ich überrascht von der Vielzahl von verschiedenen Nummern, die es gab für diese Computer. Unglaublich. Der Chat geht übrigens schon los. Felix.dd ist... Ach so, der Text kommt von oben. Felix hat hier auch ein paar Probleme. Ich habe auch gesucht, wo mein Text ist. Gut, aber das lassen wir jetzt einfach ein bisschen laufen. Wenn mehrere Leute sich da treffen, bei www.fritz.de slash speakers slash chat, dann könnt ihr euch da untereinander ein bisschen unterhalten über hoffentlich das Thema heute. Java und ActiveX. Banko de Gaia mit einer wunderbaren Nummer aus dem Soundtrack zu Synthetic Plashes. Ein Film, den man sehen sollte und der zum Diskutieren anregt. Ist aber gar nicht unser Thema, genauso wie Tamagotchi heute nicht unser Thema sind, obwohl man da sicher eine Menge philosophieren könnte. Besonders Java, genau, wir machen eine Tamagotchi Sendung. Lass uns Sponsoren dann aber. Java und ActiveX sind unsere Themen. Wenn ihr diese Sendung hier kennt, Chaosradio gibt es an ihrem letzten Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz. Eine Sendung, die sich mit Computerthemen befasst, und zwar nicht mit Themen wie so richtig Netscape richtig ein, sondern mit Themen, die etwas tiefer gehen, unter anderem auch tiefer in Netscape oder in den Microsoft Internet Explorer oder welchen Browser ihr auch immer benutzt. Da wird nämlich viel rumgebastelt. Und wenn wir Java und ActiveX sagen, dann könntet ihr mal vielleicht mir und den Hörer ein bisschen näher bringen, was das überhaupt ist. Was hat mein Internetbrowser mit Java zu tun? Was hat er mit ActiveX zu tun? Was sind das für Wörter?
Ja, Java und ActiveX sind natürlich erstmal Schlagwörter, die eine ganze Menge umfassen und ein bisschen schwammig versuchen, als Zukunftsleitmotiv für verschiedene Firmen zu verschiedenen Zwecken zu dienen.
Es geht um es kurz zu machen, darum Programmelemente aus dem Netz zu laden.
Nicht nur, nicht nur. Das ist erstmal das, was man als normaler Netzbenutzer... Das ist das, was man als normaler Netzbenutzer von Java und ActiveX entgegen nimmt. Es sind erstmal, wenn man als Klicker durch das Internet schreitet, kleine aktive Bestandteile von Webseiten, die also mehr sind als nur ein Bild, sondern konkret auf Eingaben reagieren können und Programme, die direkt beim Benutzer ausgeführt werden und nicht im Server.
Das sagte ich doch bereits schon.
Ist doch egal, lass ihn doch einfach ausreden.
Er lässt mich ja auch nicht ausreden.
Ich kann das auf alles kürzer zusammenfassen, aber dann versteht wieder keiner was.
Guck mal diese Ethernet-Mentalität.
Ja, das musst du jetzt erklären, Tim.
Andreas, mach mal weiter.
Also, es gibt da zwei verschiedene Ansätze für diese aktiven Komponenten in Webseiten. Nämlich einmal den Ansatz von Microsoft, der nennt sich ActiveX, und dann den Ansatz der Firma Sun, der heißt Java. Und im Prinzip versuchen beide, dasselbe zu erreichen, nämlich alles bunter, schöner, schneller zu machen. Und die verwendeten Technologien sind aber grundlegend verschieden. Jetzt stellen wir erst mal das Telefon von Andi weg, weil es nachschmiert.
Also Java und ActiveX sind beides Programmiersprachen, die...
Na, das ist so nicht richtig. Java ist auch eine Programmiersprache. Also das grundlegende Problem bei den Technologien ist die Begriffsverwirrung, die da betrieben wird von allen Seiten. Java ist sowohl eine Programmiersprache als auch eine Umgebung, als auch ein machine-abhängiger Bytecode. Und ActiveX ist eine......eine offene System-Schnittstelle... .eine offene System-Schnittstelle für Programme für Intel-Binaries.
Genau, Windows-Programme sozusagen. Das ist es im Prinzip im Überblick.
Und was gibt es da drei Stunden drüber zu reden?
Ja, warum ist das eigentlich alles so wichtig? Genau, das ist eine große Frage, wir haben ja auch ein bisschen überlegt, ob das jetzt wirklich ein Thema ist für uns. Wichtig ist es deshalb, weil es derzeit die Plattform-Diskussion wieder angeheizt hat. Also noch vor einiger Zeit fing ja die Welt an, sich so langsam auf Windows einzuschießen und wozu brauchen wir denn eigentlich noch was anderes? Und gerade die waberige Tour, die die Firma Apple so bestritten hat, hat das ja auch belegt. Und natürlich ist damit nicht alles schon zu Ende, weil Windows taugt halt einfach nicht für alle Anwendungen. Es wird auf jeden Fall noch auf lange Sicht andere Systeme daneben geben. Aber ob sich auch wirklich Windows auf lange Zeit als die dominante Plattform halten kann, das ist halt jetzt noch offen und nicht zuletzt eben durch die Einführung von Java.
Also kann man sagen, dass so was wie Java der Versuch ist, über das Internet, an den er dann nach Hoffnung von vielen großen Firmen irgendwann, an das er nach Hoffnung von vielen großen Firmen irgendwann alle, die einen Computer haben, angeschlossen sind, dass man versucht darüber ein einheitliches Betriebssystem zu schaffen unter Umständen auch?
Ja, also ich glaube das Wort muss jetzt Plattform heißen und nicht mehr Betriebssystem. Bis jetzt war es halt immer nur das Betriebssystem und die Programme koppeln sich jetzt aber im zunehmenden Maße von der einzigen Oberfläche Betriebssystem ab. Ein gutes Beispiel ist auch das neue Betriebssystem, das Apple jetzt plant. Wenn man darin dann entwickelt, dann kann man Programme schreiben, die sowohl unter dem neuen Apple Betriebssystem laufen, aber man kann auch durch einfaches Neuübersetzen des Programms dieselbe Software unmodifiziert auch unter Windows laufen lassen. Also nochmal sozusagen darunter gelegt, ohne dass es jetzt sofort Einbußen in der Geschwindigkeit oder Flexibilität haben müsste. Frameworks, weitere Umgebungen, die einfach noch mehr den Zwecken dienen. Weil Betriebssysteme sind viel zu kompliziert, als dass sie wirklich für die Erstellung von einfachen Anwendungen taugen. Dieses Aufkommen von Scriptsprachen und auch einfachen Umgebungen, wie Visual Basic zeigen das immer wieder. Man braucht noch sehr viel mehr als nur dieses Betriebssystem, diese relativ immer noch maschinennahe Abstraktion, wie ein Programm sozusagen mit dem Benutzer kommuniziert. Aber das interessiert einen in der Regel nicht. Bei 100, 200 Programmen möchte man halt einfach nur mal ein bisschen dies, mal ein bisschen das machen und nicht jedes Mal wieder das Rad neu erfinden. Und darin sind die heutigen Betriebssysteme eigentlich noch relativ schwach. Also einfach dieser frühere Auftrag von Betriebssystemen, du sollst die Hardware abkapseln. Ich denke, das haben wir jetzt erreicht. Jetzt geht es aber nicht nur darum, die Hardware abzukapseln, sondern es muss halt auch brauchbare und wirklich gut benutzbare Abstraktion gefunden werden, wie interagiere ich mit meinem Benutzer. Man muss halt mehr als nur ein Fenster aufmachen und okay sein.
Interagiert wird übrigens hier im Blue Moon Chat auch. www.fritz.de Da treffen sich inzwischen einige Leute und Lutz ist auch dabei und kann ein paar Fragen beantworten, wahrscheinlich. Es gibt natürlich kein Chaosradio, ohne dass da noch einige Sachen zu beachten wären bei unserem Thema. Also wir reden hier nicht über Java und ActiveX und erklären euch, wie das funktioniert, sondern wir werden natürlich über einige Probleme mit diesen beiden Plattformen reden. Fast jetzt eine schöne Überleitung war da mit einer von euch weiter. Was denn los, seid ihr stoned oder was? Das dürfen wir nicht öffentlich sagen, das ist doch öffentlich recht der Herr Sender. Du kannst hier sagen, was du willst.
Nein, du warst gerade so schön am Fragen, wir waren gerade so schön am Beantworten, da dachten wir, bleiben wir vielleicht bei dem Spiegel.
Okay, dann frage ich mal weiter, ist denn das nicht auch gefährlich unter Umständen?
Oh, du stellst die Sicherheitsfrage. Jetzt, Leute, ein neues Kapitel.
Also wir haben sozusagen für die Dramaturgie, insbesondere für die zweite Stunde eben den ActiveX Hack, wie man ihn auch irgendwie nennt, der ja von einigen Leuten vom Club durchgeführt wurde, wo es also um die Fernsteuerbarkeit des Computers aus dem Netz herausging, in diesem Fall um die Fernsteuerbarkeit auf, natürlich der Homebanking Software. Da gehen wir in der zweiten Stunde eben in Detail drauf ein. Jetzt in der ersten Stunde wollten wir uns theoretisch darauf konzentrieren, das erstmal so grundsätzlich zu erleuchten und da gibt es erstmal einen Unterschied festzustellen, den ich vielleicht kurz anfache zu erläutern und dann an Tim weitergebe, das ist nämlich der, wie gesagt bei ActiveX haben wir eine offene System-Schnittstelle, das heißt die Programme, die da kommen, jetzt mal unabhängig von der Frage, wie die kommen, die dürfen dann alles, was der eingelogte Benutzer auch kann. Da gibt es also keine Sicherheitsarchitektur, die da irgendwas noch verhindert, sondern das ist einfach offensnick aus. Und Java ist wie gesagt eine Sprache zunächst einmal, die wird dann interpretiert und die Ausführung findet in einer sogenannten Sicherheitsumgebung, auch Sandbox genannt, statt. Die wird zwar jetzt wieder aufgeweicht, das ist ein anderes Kapitel, aber da ist zunächst einmal so was wie eine Sicherheitsarchitektur überhaupt vorhanden. Das ist erstmal ein ganz grober Unterschied. Und zum anderen gibt es dann noch ein Stichwort, das heißt Software-Authentifizierung. Ich denke, da kommen wir ein bisschen später zu.
Wir werden nachher, das solltest du noch sagen, wir werden nachher auch noch ein Telefon-Interview durchführen.
Richtig, das ist dann, in der zweiten Stunde gehen wir auf den Heck ein bisschen ein und telefonieren auch mit einem derjenigen, der den sozusagen durchgeführt hat, um da auch ein bisschen die Reaktion und die Geschichte nochmal aufzuräumen.
Genau, und wir haben ja noch was anzukündigen. Diesmal dabei ist wieder unser Chaosklavier. Wir haben diesmal unser Versprechen endlich wahrgemacht und tatsächlich mal die ganzen Mod-Files, die uns in den letzten Monaten zugeschickt wurden, zusammengekratzt und ein paar nette ausgesucht, die wir dann hier zwischendurch spielen werden. Die Soundqualität, also die technische Soundqualität wird also diesmal etwas niedrig sein, aber...
Kannst du das mal demonstrieren, Apple Computer?
Ja, du kannst ja mal... Müller, hast du mich hier mal...
Du bist eigentlich online hier.
I think it is time we demonstrated the full power of this station.
Ja, das ist in etwa das, was wir jetzt mal haben.
Das ist hier nicht nur interaktives Radio im Radio, sondern natürlich auch für euch. Ihr werdet gleich dann hier zum Thema anrufen können.
Willst du jetzt Musik machen oder soll ich jetzt gleich Musik machen?
Nee, ich mach jetzt gleich Musik bis zum Fritz-Info. Ja, du kannst dann gleich Musik machen. Okay, ich verspreche es. Ihr könnt hier also nachher nicht nur anrufen, sondern auch ansonsten in der Zeit, in der wir nicht live auf Sendung sind, möchten wir, dass ihr weiter mitmacht. Also schreibt Fragen an uns, chaos.orb.de, sagt uns über was ihr reden wollt in dieser Sendung und schickt uns von mir aus Soundfiles. Bitte vorher fragen, wenn die größer als ein Megabyte sind. Ich hab letztens voll genervt.
Also uns interessieren vor allem die Mod-Files, weil das sind halt in der Regel Kompositionen und da halte ich mehr von als von irgendwelchen gesampelten CDs.
Also die CDs können wir uns selber überspielen.
Ansonsten Ideen, Bilder, coole Soundausrisse, Grafiken von mir aus, die für die CCC-Seiten oder für die Fritz-Seiten Johnny nackt im Internet.
Genau, ich nackt im Internet, gibt es alles schon. Und gibt es auch http-doppelbaum-slash-slash-bww-johny.
I think it is time we demonstrated the full power of this station.
Ah, dann sag ich's da halt nicht, die URL, wo ich nackt bin, pfff, egal. Interessiert da doch kein. Ich hab einen Counter eingerichtet auf diese nackte Seite, er ist jetzt bei zwei. Hat angefangen im Januar 96. Sind die den Java programmiert? Ne, ich glaub das...
Du musst die richtigen Keywords dazu schreiben.
Ich glaub, das interessiert jemand.
Nee, eben nicht, deswegen so wenig Zugriffe. Gleich geht's weiter nach dem Fritz-Info. Achso, und eins wollte ich noch sagen zu dieser Platte, von der ich ja einiges im Hintergrund spielen werde. Das ist nämlich insofern eine sehr schöne Geschichte, die hab ich zugeschickt gekriegt von einem Hörer, der wiederum hat sie von einem E-Mail-Bekannten aus Amerika. Die Firma, auf der diese Platte erschienen ist, vertreibt nur im Internet. Ich sag gleich kurz vorm Internet, die ich jetzt hier in der Sendung habe, die Adresse ist ein bisschen länger, aber für Leute, die so eine Musik mögen, die sollten sich das mal angucken. Die Band heißt Arm Beer und die Platte ist richtig, richtig klasse. So, für alle Interessierten jetzt die Adresse, jetzt sind wir in einer Computersendung. Ihr könnt mir natürlich auch eine Mail schicken, wenn ihr es jetzt nicht mitkriegt, chaos.orb.de oder john.orb.de. Also, Adresse ist im www.members.aol.com Ich bin bereit, was ich jetzt sagen muss. Ja, immer ziemlich blöde, so eine Adresse. Aber wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, schickt uns eine Mail. Da gibt es solche CDs zu bestellen und nur da, in keinem Laden zu kaufen. Hier geht es weiter mit dem Chaos Radio bei Fritz, der Computer-Bloom-Moon, auf diesen wunderbaren Sender. So Chats, ob man im IRC oder hier im Web hat, hat immer etwas äußerst Interessantes, weil es eigentlich die ersten drei Stunden hauptsächlich darum geht, ob man den anderen lesen kann und warum dann hier und nicht im IRC. Und dann fragt einer, was ist denn IRC? Ey, es geht um Java und ActiveX. Wie auch eure Browser hochfahrt, wisst ihr scheinbar, sonst würde der hier nicht reden. Erst mal pöbeln, immer erst mal anpöbeln.
Genau.
Ist gut. Erst mal steckern.
Die höhere Anzahl ist auch viel zu gut.
Steckern, genau.
Immer nur zuhören.
Von den zweitern sowieso keiner geht's, nicht wahrscheinlich.
Sauger.
Echt.
Ja, weiter geht's hier mit Java und ActiveX. Lass uns erst ein bisschen über Java reden.
Erst mal ein bisschen über Java.
Ja, reden wir ein bisschen über Java.
Der Kaffee-Krieg. Microsoft ist auf dem Softwaremarkt nahezu unangefochten. Nahezu jedes System läuft entweder unter Windows oder kann durch andere Zusätze Windows-Software verarbeiten. Microsoft hat die Plattform und kontrolliert damit die Märkte in einer Weise, die anderen Firmen das Überleben sehr schwer machen. Mit dem Aufkommen des Internets werden diese Karten neu gemischt. Mit Java hat Sun eine Alternative ins Rennen geworfen, die derzeit die besten Chancen hat, Microsoft den Plattformvorteil streitig zu machen. Was macht Java zu einem so starken Konkurrenten? Java ist eine neue Programmiersprache. Sie ist objektorientiert und daher einfacher zu strukturieren als die Sprache C, der es aber im Look und Feel noch sehr nahe steht. Java forciert die modulare Softwareentwicklung und schafft damit eine gute Basis für die Verbreitung von kleinen, wohl definierten Softwarepaketen. 2. Java ist eine virtuelle Maschine. Diese Java-VM ist unabhängig von Prozessoren und Betriebssystemen. Somit kann Java-Code, der sogenannte Byte-Code, ohne weitere Anpassungen sofort auf jedem Rechner ausgeführt werden, auch wenn dies zunächst mit signifikanten Geschwindigkeitseinbußen verbunden ist. 3. Java ist mobiler Code. Durch die Nähe zum Internet, die Integration in die populären Webbrowser und die Virtual Machine wird Java-Code zum mobilen Code. Programme können in dem Moment in kleinen Häppchen geladen werden, wenn sie gebraucht werden. Aufwendiges Vorhalten von Programmen auf Festplatten entfällt weitgehend.
4.
Java ist eine Plattform. Teil der Java-Spezifikation ist eine umfangreiche API, eine Application Programmers Interface, die von Textausgabe bis hin zum Window-Management und grafischen Fähigkeiten in 2D und 3D alles definiert bzw. definieren wird, unabhängig vom Betriebssystem, aber überall gültig. Damit ist Java eine reelle Alternative zu Windows. Die Nachteile von Java liegen, wo die Vorteile sind. Zum Beispiel in der Virtual Machine. Ein Network-Computer kann eben nur Java ausführen, andere Programmiersprachen können nicht verwendet werden. Dass alle bestehende Software in Java übersetzt wird, kann getrost bezweifelt werden. Neue internetnahe und performance-unkritische Programme jedoch werden wohl ihren Weg in die Java-Welt finden. Vor allem, wenn es sich dabei vorher um C-Programme handelte. Die Transition von C++ fällt da schon etwas schwerer, ist aber auch möglich. Ein anderes Problem ist die Geschwindigkeit. Zwar holen die neuen sogenannten Just-In-Time-Compiler kräftig auf, doch bestehen zumindest derzeit noch starke Differenzen zu anderen Sprachen mit nativen Compilern. Echte Compiler für Java und die angekündigten Java-Chips könnten da etwas wettmachen. Microsoft ist ebenfalls Lizenznehmer von Java, hat aber ganz andere Ziele. Microsoft sieht Java selbst nicht als Plattform, sondern lediglich als neue Programmiersprache, was so falsch natürlich auch nicht ist. Die Redmonder Bande bewegt sich jedoch auf dünnem Eis. Zu wenig Support für Java bringt sie in die Defensive, zu viel Unterstützung tut ihnen auch nicht gut. Daher versucht Microsoft derzeit massiv eigene Plattform-Standards neben denen von Sun zu etablieren. Zum Beispiel die Application Foundation Classes anstatt der für Java Foundation Classes von Sun. Und den anderen Fuzzies. Egal was aus Java wird, es herrscht wieder etwas Wind nach langer Stille. Der selbst gefällige Software-Gigant muss zeigen, ob man mit Geld alle Probleme lösen kann.
Bei dem, was du gerade referiert hast, das schwingt so ein bisschen mit, dass Sun versucht, unter anderem durch Java diese Vormachtstellung von Microsoft zu beenden.
Ja, zumindest stark einzuschränken.
Glaubt ihr, dass das klappt?
Na ja, mit Voraussagen ist es ja immer sehr schwierig. Ich würde es so formulieren, sie haben derzeit die größten Chancen. Die Unterstützung von Java ist sehr breitbeinig und sie haben vor allem den Vorteil, dass sie mit Java Bereiche erreichen, die für Windows absolut tabu sind. Zum Beispiel kleine Geräte oder auch diese Smart Cards, in denen ja auch irgendwann Programme laufen müssen für Krypto-Geschichten und ähnliche Sachen, oder so Ethernet-Hubs. So kleine Geräte, die einfach nur bestimmten Zwecken dienen, die auch programmiert werden müssen und wo es schon immer wünschenswert war, flexible Software schnell austauschen zu können. Die Konfiguration oder irgendwie Software-Updates, solche Sachen, das haben zwar viele auch gemacht, über ladbare Roms, auch über Chipkarten, über anschließbare Festplatten und was nicht alles. Und Java bietet jetzt das erste Mal für alle eine allgemeine Plattform, die im Prinzip genau diese Probleme wunderbar adressiert. Sehr viel schwieriger ist es für Java, genau da Konkurrenz zu machen, wo eben Windows pregiert. Nämlich Integration Desktop, Zugriff auf diese ganzen an den Desktop angeschlossenen Geräte. Da wird Java sicherlich in den nächsten zwei Jahren keine sehr großen Fortschritte machen. Aber kleinere Anwendungen, die eben nicht so viel Umfang brauchen, sind eben ganz gut. Ein anderer Vorteil ist eben die Unabhängigkeit vom Prozessor und die Unabhängigkeit überhaupt von Betriebssystemen. Also Java skaliert auch eigentlich recht gut. Sprich, es läuft auf sehr, sehr, sehr kleinen Systemen. Also ist es vorstellbar, dass es dort das tut, was es tun muss. Aber eben auch auf großen Desktop-Rechnern, die recht schnell sind.
Nun kommt ja Java vom Kaffee. Also Java ist eigentlich ein Kaffee. Und wenn du sagst, dass Java als Sprache oder als was auch immer in kleinen Geräten funktioniert, dann heißt das, man guckt da schon weiter als den Computer, wie wir ihn jetzt auf dem Schreibtisch stehen haben, mit Monitor oder so, sondern an alle kleinen Geräte, in denen ein, weiß nicht, irgendein Chip arbeitet. Das heißt irgendwie, zum Beispiel dann auch die Kaffeemaschine könnte irgendwann durchaus Java gesteuert sein.
Also die Java Station von Sun heißt intern auch, Koffie beschnitten.
Na ja, der andere Trend, in dem das eingebettet ist, sind natürlich die Tendenz zum Netzcomputer. Also insbesondere in der, sozusagen, Businesswelt, in der Geschäftswelt denken die halt schon darüber nach, im Prinzip wieder zu Mainframes mit Terminals zu kommen, bloß dass die Terminals diesmal schlau sein sollen. Also zum Beispiel eben Buchhaltungsgeschichten und so fort. Dass da eine Menge bereits lokal vor Ort processiert verarbeitet werden kann durch Eingabemasken und so fort. Mit einer gewissen Eigenintelligenz, Textverarbeitung oder ähnliches. Und dann aber letztendlich eben wieder in ein Netz, also ins Netz als Computer hineingetragen wird. Also das Netz ist das Netz für sich wird sozusagen zum Computer. Und die Leistungsfähigkeit geht ein bisschen vom Client wieder weg. Genau.
Weil die sind ja auch alle viel zu groß. Es ist halt interessant zu sehen, dass ausgerechnet Sun damit hochkommt. Weil Sun ist im Unix-Markt der stärkste Player. Und die Philosophie von Unix im Bezug auf Mehrbenutzersysteme war immer die, es gibt einen Host am großen Rechner und angeschlossen daran sind Terminals. Und das findet man in vielen Firmen auch heute noch gerade so, wo gebucht wird und eingetragen wird, wo also sozusagen die Interaktion sich auf relativ einfache Dinge bezieht. So Blättern durch Datensätze, das Auffinden von einzelnen Datensätzen. Für solche Sachen ist ein normales ASCII-Terminal wunderbar ausreichend. Und Unix bietet dann die Möglichkeit, eben diese ganze Dateispeicherung zentral zu haben, sodass man da nicht so große Probleme hat. Wenn man sich heute PC-Netze anschaut, da wurde ja mal viel drüber geredet, dass irgendwie die Dezentralisierung die Lösung aller Probleme ist, ist sie natürlich nicht, weil jetzt muss sich ein Administrator darum kümmern, jede einzelne Festplatte in jedem Rechner, die natürlich auch noch kaputt gehen kann, auch noch zu back-upen. Dafür sind diese Betriebssysteme, die da drauf laufen, vor allem Windows nicht unbedingt wunderbar geeignet, sondern da braucht man auch nochmal spezielle Software, die so ein Betriebssystem gar nicht drin ist. Sodass also der Overhead, wie das jetzt mittlerweile so schön heißt, im Schlagwort The Total Cost of Ownership, also die effektiven tatsächlichen Kosten, die ein solches Gerät verursacht, die sind halt relativ hoch und die Probleme sind auch relativ hoch. Und die Idee mit dem Netzcomputer ist eigentlich nur die Kombination aus dem, was man nämlich haben will, nämlich einen intelligenten Client, dass man also komplexere Programme, komplexe Eingaben, auch das Arbeiten mit multimedialen Daten, Bildern und Filmen usw. lokal machen kann. Aber dass die Speicherung, die zentrale Verwaltung, immer noch auch wirklich zentral liegt, was einfach die Verwaltung des Computersystems vereinfacht. Und da ist der Netzcomputer ein wirklich brauchbarer Ansatz. Und ich denke, wenn Sun mit Java erstmal Erfolg hat, dann werden sie ihn genau in dem Bereich haben. Das zeigt sich dadurch, dass zum Beispiel Hersteller von X-Windows-Terminals, also diesem grafischen Anschlusssystem für Unix, dass die jetzt ganz massiv auf Netzwerkcomputer gehen. Also die ganzen Player, die müssen auch nicht so sehr viel Energie reinstecken, um aus ihren Geräten Netzcomputer zu machen. Sie müssen eigentlich nur Java portieren und das war es dann eigentlich. Und das ist halt vergleichsweise wirklich.
Naja, der Netzcomputer-Markt ist aber in erster Linie für Firmen interessant und weniger für den Heimatkinder sollte man dabei auch sehen.
Das ist so. Also derzeit ist es noch so. Ob sich das ändert, daran wird sich der wahre Erfolg von Java messen lassen.
Also ich möchte meine Daten nicht bei meinem Provalor speichern müssen.
Ja, aber vielleicht in deinem Intranet auf deinem Server.
Dass du ihn zuhause hast, gehört ja in ihren besseren Haushalt, so ein Intranet.
Ich habe mir jetzt CAD5-Kabel in alle Räume gelegt, sogar aufs Klo.
100 Megabit direkt in die Schüssel.
Ja, da gehen ja dann auch doch viele Daten hin inzwischen. Wenn ihr Fragen oder Kommentare habt zum Thema Java, könnt ihr uns natürlich anrufen. Ich habe gerade so ein bisschen Einführung gehört, selbst wenn ihr euch da nicht so technisch mit beschäftigt, aber wenn ihr zum Beispiel im Internet rumsourft, im WWW, dann habt ihr sicher irgendwie schon mal was von Java gelesen, sei es, dass ihr bei der Konfiguration eures Browsers irgendwie was einstellen müsst oder dass ihr vielleicht einen alten Browser habt und ihr sagt plötzlich, je Java, das verstehe ich nicht und so. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, wenn ihr Kommentare habt, ruft an.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist gescheitert. 0331 für Potsdam, 7481 110.
Die Samples sind cool, aber musikalisch ist es ja doch eher bisschen so...
Hörer-Einspielung.
Also ich würde sagen, wir bewerten eigentlich die Musik jetzt nicht mal.
Das ist einfach logisch bewerten, wir sind hier auf dem freien Markt.
Naja, also mich haut es jetzt auch nicht unbedingt vom Stuhl. Aber ich finde die Samples ganz gut.
Ich finde die Samples super geil. Also muss man kurz auch wieder erklären, dass ist Musik eingeschickt von einem Hörer über Internet, ein sogenanntes Mod-File. Natürlich kann man ruhig sagen, dass es musikalisch 80er ist, macht doch nichts. Liegt natürlich an den Sounds, die da laufen, aber was das interessante ist, dass da so schöne AT&T-Samples bei sind, also von irgendeinem Operator, der einen versucht zu verbinden oder fragt, wie sie einem helfen kann und so. Also ein durchaus dieser Sendung entsprechendes Mod-File.
Aber wir haben noch ein paar Schärfe, wenn du mal in die Da-Beisen, da wird ein paar lustige Sachen gekommen.
Kriegt der jetzt eigentlich G-Mod? Nein, ne? Keine Ahnung. Nein, nein, guckt dann nicht. Sollte mal gehen. Tja, weiter geht's mit die Java und ActiveX. Wir bleiben erst noch ein bisschen bei Java. Wie gesagt, ab 11 Uhr gibt's hier Näheres über den ActiveX-Hack, was das überhaupt ist für alle, die durch das nicht mitbekommen haben. Sehr interessante Sache auch für Leute, die sich für Computer nicht interessieren, übrigens, wenn sie es dahin durchgehalten haben. Wir bleiben aber erst mal ein bisschen bei Java.
Ja, wir können ja vielleicht mal sagen, warum wir finden, dass Java toll ist. Also Java ist sehr umstritten, auch im Internet und sehr kontroverses Thema. Es gibt viele, die dafür sind, andere sind strikt dagegen. Und einer der Gründe, der immer wieder gegen Java genannt wird, ist Performance. Es ist zu langsam, es funktioniert alles nicht richtig und man könnte damit nichts Kompliziertes machen. Die erste komplizierte Applikation in Java, die ich gesehen habe, ist Quake. Jemand hat Quake in Java nachprogrammiert als Applet.
Quake ist dieses Bala, bala, bala Blutspritz-Spielchen.
Ich glaube, wir können voraussetzen, dass alle wissen, was Quake ist, oder? Ja, es war zugegebenermaßen langsam, aber das lag darin, dass es noch keinen Just-in-Time-Compiler hatte. Diese Virtual Machine-Geschichte muss nicht unbedingt langsamer sein als ein nativ kompilierter Code, wie viele immer wieder behaupten. Wenn es interpretiert wird, wie das heute noch geschieht, ist es selbstverständlich langsamer. Aber wenn man es mal anders betrachtet, nämlich diesen Byte-Code nur als Zwischenschritt bei der Kompilierung vor der eigentlichen Übersetzung in den Machine-Code des Computers, so kann da durchaus hinten wieder was Performantes bei rauskommen. Und ich denke, dass Just-in-Time-Compiler oder auch andere Compiler, die nach dem Download des App-Apps komplett übersetzen, eine Performance-Verbesserung bringen werden. Und vor allen Dingen, es wird auch bald Compiler geben, die keinen Byte-Code erzeugen, sondern einen nativen Code erzeugen, sodass man mit Java speziell für die Maschine Programme schreiben kann. Das wird dann selbstverständlich auch performen.
Genau. Also es gibt von der Sprache her selber eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund, warum es jetzt besonders langsamer sein sollte als C. Nur eben dieses Modell, was gewählt wurde, das......will halt vor allem erst mal diese Cross-Plattform-Möglichkeit zeigen. Das war das Wichtigste. Und es hat sich da halt kein Problem, später die Performance noch nachzuschieben. Das wird auch kommen.
Und die Sprache Java an und für sich ist eigentlich auch gar nicht so schlecht. Zugegeben, sie hat ein paar Features nicht, zum Beispiel kein Multiple inheritance und sie ist in ein paar Stellen ein bisschen unelegant. Es gibt drei verschiedene Sorten Typen und nicht bloß eine.
Das geht jetzt in den religiösen Bereich über.
Es ist alles wesentlich besser als C++. Es gibt keine Ponta mehr. Es gibt Garbage Collection. Man muss sich nicht mehr um seinen Speicher kümmern.
Die Programme können nicht mehr abstürzen.
Genau.
Wenn ich jetzt sozusagen mal kurz versuche, die andere Seite des Bildschirms einzunehmen, was sind dann sinnvolle Applikationen, die jetzt mit Java irgendwie realisiert sind, die nicht aus bunten animierten Grafiken bestehen oder aus ballerballer Blutstritt spielen?
Also bei der populären Suchmaschine Alta Vista kann man in eine Textzeile seinen Namen eingeben, seinen Suchbegriff eingeben, Return drücken, Komm 1000 Links, aber man hat auch die Möglichkeit, nachdem man das getan hat, kurz darunter auf Live Topics zu klicken und dann kriegt man ein Java-Applet, was einem zu den eingegebenen Schlüsselwörtern, nach denen man suchen möchte, eine grafisch aufbereitete Netzstruktur von Bedeutungsbereichen, in denen diese Schlüsselwörter sich wahrscheinlich befinden könnten. Ich habe es schon gesehen. Ich habe es schon gesehen. Ich habe es schon gesehen. Ich habe es schon gesehen. Ich habe es schon gesehen. Ich habe es schon gesehen. Das bringt schon was, unabhängig davon, ob es jetzt inhaltlich auch tatsächlich funktioniert. Dieses Java Applet ist eine wunderbare Sache, weil man muss sich nicht erstmal dafür jetzt irgendwie einen speziellen Client machen, der dann auch Windows portiert werden muss, auf Macintosh portiert werden muss und der dann unter Unix sowieso nicht läuft, sondern das läuft halt einfach überall. Das ist überschaubar. Und um so ausdauernder Java-Implementierungen werden und schneller werden werden, wird auch die Komplexität dieser Programme zunehmen. Man muss es auch so sehen. Noch gibt es nicht so viele Leute, die seit Jahren Java programmieren. Das ist für viele noch relativ neu. Es ist zwar nah an den bisherigen Programmiersprachen, aber es ist natürlich zunächst einmal eine andere. Man muss sich ein paar Sachen abgewöhnen und ein paar Sachen angewöhnen. Und wenn das erfolgt ist, sehe ich da eigentlich gar keine Bedenken.
Ich bin ja völlig erstaunt, dass ihr hier einfach sitzt und das okay findet alles.
Sonst gibt es doch immer nur Bemäcker.
Wir reden jetzt über die Sprache Java und nicht über die anderen Aspekte wie z.B. Virtual Machine oder Sicherheit. Und die Sprache Java kann man an sich erstmal lassen. Wie gesagt, wir sind Fans von anderen Sprachen. Aber ich denke, als allgemeine Bildungsmaßnahme, um zu zeigen, dass Garbage Collection doch toll ist und das C++ nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss ist, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, ist die Sprache Java schon geeignet.
Da stehen nur noch die Applikationen, die nicht aus diesem bunten, bewegten Grafik sind.
Unser Marketing Guy.
Endlich, endlich.
Ich finde es schön, dass Andy immer da sitzt und so ein bisschen...
Es wird doch alles so langsam.
Ich kann leider nicht richtig steckern. Ich mache das ja gerne. Aber ich kann nicht richtig steckern bei Java. Alles, was mir auffällt, ist, dass immer, wenn irgendwas mit Java passiert und der Netscape, dass die Scheiße abstürzt.
Ja, aber das liegt natürlich an Netscape und nicht an Java. Also es liegt ab Daumständen auch an den Sun-Hackern, die irgendwie Java auch relativ quick und dirty auf den Markt geworfen haben. Das haben die auch zugegeben. Aber sie tun was dran. Jetzt ist gerade die 1.1-Spezifikation vorgestellt worden. Die 1.2 ist schon on the move und wird auch noch dieses Jahr das Licht der Welt erblicken. Es ist mittlerweile viel dazugekommen. Vor allem in dem vierten Bereich, den wir vorhin angerissen haben, der besonderen Bedeutung von Java, nämlich der Plattform. Denn mit der Java-Spezifikation geht nicht nur die Spezifikation der Programmiersprache und der Virtual Machine ein, sondern auch ein kompletter Satz von Programmierschnittstellen, wie man eben auf bestimmte Dienste auf dem Computer, wo das Programm dann läuft, zugreift. Aber völlig cross-Plattform, überhaupt nicht mehr auf einen bestimmten Betriebssystemtyp zugeschnitten. Das holt natürlich viel aus bestehenden Konzepten. Diese Java Foundation Classes sind also ein vollständiges Framework, ein Satz von APIs und Objekten, wo man schnell Fenster aufmachen kann, seine Listen, Scrollbars, Buttons, die ganzen Menüs und des Kommandos einbauen. Also alles, was man so auch unter Windows tun würde, um eine vollwertige Anwendung zu machen, das ist dort definiert und soll eben, und das ist auch zu erwarten, dass es halbwegs funktionieren wird, eben auf allen Betriebssystemen laufen.
Also nochmal langsam, da wahrscheinlich höchstens 0, 5% der zugehörenden Meute Programmierer sind oder Programmiererinnen, von dem bisschen, was ich weiß, also nehmen wir mal an, ich will eine Anwendung programmieren, da muss ich natürlich auch die ganzen, bei Windows oder bei Macintosh oder bei X-Windows oder so eine Schicht, muss ich natürlich auch die grafische Oberfläche mit programmieren gestalten.
So, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel, eine kleine Textverarbeitung.
Genau, und das soll irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ein File-Opening-System sein. Also ich will irgendwie entweder Command-O oder welchen Befehl auch immer auf der Tastatur drücken und ich will ein File öffnen. Das heißt, das muss der Programmierer natürlich definieren, irgendwie in seinem Programm. Der muss das möglich machen, dass sich dann da dieses Datalsystem öffnet und wahrscheinlich auch das noch im Einzelnen programmiert. Und das soll jetzt mit Java dann wirklich so funktionieren, dass ich das einmal programmiere und das funktioniert dann und auf Mac, so wie es auf Mac funktioniert, und auf Windows, so wie es auf Windows funktioniert und so weiter. Genau, das ist ja toll.
Das ist auch toll, ja, also die Idee ist ja eigentlich gut. Das wollten wir eigentlich auch schon immer haben. Nur über den Weg hat man sich halt lange gestritten. Und Sanja hat jetzt einen enormen Erfolg, zumindest was jetzt den Hype betrifft, gelandet und eben nicht vollständig zu unrecht. Also sicherlich ist einiges erstmal übertrieben worden, zum Beispiel die Sachen mit der Geschwindigkeit. Aber das sind eben wirklich Dinge, die sich legen können.
Das ist so vom Konzept her. Das kommt vielleicht auch daran, dass Sanja nicht programmieren kann, genauso wie nicht wie Netscape. Also wenn das alles langsam ist und abstürzt, ist noch kein Beweis dafür, dass die Technologie schlecht ist.
Aber wie können dann Leute, die nicht programmieren können, so eine Technologie entwickeln?
Microsoft kann auch nicht programmieren und haben es über das Marketing gemacht. Es gibt vielleicht ein paar Leute bei Sun, konkret dieser James Gosling und der Guy Steele, die aus der Libs-Community kommen und die schon Ahnung von Programmiersprachen und so weiter haben. Die haben sich Gedanken, das Konzept gemacht, hatten eine Idee. Das haben sie dann an die Codes Club gegeben. Die Codes Club haben das runterprogrammiert und sich nicht viel Mühe gegeben. Deshalb läuft das alles nicht vernünftig.
Sie könnten auch schlecht ernährt gewesen sein.
Fragen von euch zu Java gibt es überhaupt keine. Hier klingelt nicht ein Telefon, was irgendwie ganz genial ist. Sonst klingelt nämlich immer mindestens eine Leitung. Da ist immer der drauf, der fragt, ob es Tech-Vet noch gibt oder jemand anderes fragt, wer beim nächsten Frasconsert spielt. Diese Leitung klingelt immer. Selbst der ist weg. Nein, da ist er wieder.
Wir können das nicht sehen, Johnny.
Vielleicht habt ihr ein Telefonnummer noch nicht gegeben. Ich hab die schon tausendmal gucken, ob die wirklich was wollen. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hallo, hier ist Jörn.
Jörn, hi.
Ja, ich habe mal eine Frage zu Java. Und zwar habe ich im Internet gelesen, dass man damit 3D-Animationen verwirklichen kann. Habe so etwas aber über das Netscape noch nie gesehen auf einer Seite.
Da könnten zwei Sachen mit gemeint sein. Das eine ist, dass Java auch eine Programmiersprache der Wahl ist für VRML. Du hast jetzt nach 3D vor allem gefragt. Also VRML, sagt dir das was? VRML ist im Prinzip, was HTML für Text sei, VRML für 3D-Objekte. Das gibt es ja auch schon mittlerweile in einer 2.0-Spezifikation. Die Software kommt da noch nicht so ganz hinterher. In der Windows gibt es da schon so einiges. Auf anderen Plattformen kommt das erst so. Das ist dann ein Standard, wie man 3D-Objekte austauschen kann und wie man auch einfache Animationen machen kann.
Ist das jetzt Java-spezifisch oder geht das auch mit anderen Programmiersprachen?
Das geht auch mit anderen Programmiersprachen, auch zum Beispiel JavaScript. Da wird sicherlich noch ein bisschen mehr das Land sehen. Letzten Endes kann man in jeder Programmiersprache 3D-Animationen machen. Die Frage ist halt nur, in welcher Umgebung soll das laufen. Wenn das alles im Internet ist und erstmal überall laufen soll, hat Java natürlich wieder einen großen Vorteil. Zumal es auch eine richtige 3D-API geben wird für Java, die vielleicht noch in diesem Jahr das Licht der Welt erblickt.
Ja, das war dann auch schon meine Frage.
Alles klar.
In der Stelle vielleicht ein wichtiger Einwurf. Die Programmiersprachen Java und JavaScript haben nicht das geringste, aber auch überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun.
Das wollte ich nämlich auch mal fragen. Hier im Blue Moon Chat übrigens www.fritz.de slash speakers slash chat wird übrigens gerade festgestellt, dass das Thema nicht unbedingt massenmäßig, massenkompatibel ist. Aber das wird sich gleich erinnern, wenn wir über den ActiveX Hack reden. Und Lutz ist immer noch dabei, das finde ich schön. Hallo Lutz. Sind ja auch nicht massenkompatibel. Naja, wer ist das sowieso mehr so? Hey, hi, wer ist denn da am Telefon?
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich immer eine ganz grundlegende Frage stellen. Sag mal, wie funktioniert eigentlich dieses Vollduplex Prinzip auf einer Zweidraht-Telefonleitung? Ich meine, sind das dann Three-State-Leitungen, oder wie läuft das? Ich will auch gar kein Fahnen drüber.
Du redest von den Modem 56k Technologien, oder wovon?
Ja, von den ganz alten, von den ganz alten. Also ich meine, dass auch HasLink funktioniert etc. und so weiter. Also dieses ganze System, das man halt senden und empfangen kann in der gleichen Zeit.
Du weißt aber schon, dass wir prinzipiell bei Java sind.
Das wärst du nicht, wenn wir Niedervrückweis Technologie erklären wollten.
Hast du das nicht mal studiert?
Ja, aber ich fange jetzt nicht an, das im Handbuch der Nachrichtentechnik irgendwie zu zitieren. Lassen wir das.
Ja gut, dann spiel mal ein bisschen Musik, so ein paar Motze.
Das ist ein guter Weg, genau.
Ein schöner Neustart, machen wir mal. Wieso, du kannst ja nur abbrechen.
Dann nirgendwo ist dein Absturz schöner als auf einem Apple Macintosh.
Das war kein Absturz, das möchte ich genau.
Erkennt jemand das Gefühl, dass wenn man lange im Urlaub war und wieder nach Hause kommt, uns erst mal wieder bauen.
Das ist ein schönes Gefühl, allerdings wenn das macht.
So, jetzt wird hier langsam auch ein bisschen mehr durcheinander geredet. Das freut mich. Na ja, ihr seht immer so viel Wert aus Chaosradio. Und dann seid ihr alle so nett immer. Erst mal anfangen zu stecken hier. Achso, ihr könnt übrigens weiter anrufen. 0331 für Potsdam, 74, 81, 110. Die Fragen sollten schon in Richtung Java oder ActiveX gehen, wäre schon ganz praktisch, weil man darüber reden will. Ist sicher nicht ein Thema, worüber jetzt viele Leute was zu sagen haben. Ihr könnt auch blöde Fragen stellen. Also eigentlich bin ich ja dafür da, die doofen Fragen zu stellen. Aber es geht nicht darum, dass nur weil die Jungs hier richtig Durchblick haben, dass man sich jetzt irgendwie als Insider zeigen muss oder als Java-Hacker oder was weiß ich was. Sondern ihr könnt irgendwie fragen, wie ist das eigentlich? Dafür sind wir ja hier, Chaosradio 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110. Hi, wer ist denn da? Hi, Achim.
Ich wollte fragen, Java ist ja auch eine interpretierte Sprache. Ist das richtig verstanden?
Das ist so nicht ganz richtig.
Also es ist nicht falsch.
Es ist nicht falsch. Es ist von Java nicht definiert, ob es ein interpretierte oder ein komponierte Sprache ist. Java wird derzeit von den meisten Systemen in eine Java-Virtual Machine Sprache komponiert. Und dieser Bytecode wird dann heutzutage noch interpretiert. Es ist aber genauso gut vorstellbar, dass das Java-Programm direkt komponiert wird, wie das mit Cedarfall ist, oder aber auch, dass der Bytecode nochmal komponiert wird.
Ja, ich habe auch letztens in einer News Group was darüber gelesen, ob da jemand den Vorschlag gemacht hat, den Glue-Compiler mit einem neuen Backend zu versehen, sodass man dann halt direkt einen Java-Code rauskriegt und so dann C in Java übersetzen kann. Und umgekehrt könnte man das dann eben auch machen.
Das ist leider ein bisschen schwierig, weil der Java-Bytecode nicht wirklich universell ist. Also für einige Sprachen geht das sicherlich. Ich denke, für C ist das möglich. Es gibt auch mittlerweile ein Schema zu Java-Bytecode-Compilern. Auch Ada und einige andere Sprachen ist aber leider nicht universell. Also nicht jede Sprache wird sich in Java-Bytecode kompilieren lassen.
Ja, das ist klar, weil Sprachen immer ihre Spezialitäten haben, die in anderen Sprachen nicht...
Man hätte es auch so machen können, aber... Ich meine, einer der Vorteile bei Java, die es jetzt auch gerade für C auch schwierig macht, ist die Sache mit diesen Pointern. Die gibt es halt nicht unter Java. Das Abstürzen ist ja eigentlich auch erstmal nicht möglich, aus der Sprache selber heraus, durch fehlerhaftes Programmieren. Und ein C-Programm muss halt auch abstürzen können.
Das könnte es ja dann gar nicht mehr. Wo hast denn du die Ahnung her, die du da gerade an den Tag legst? Was machst du beruflich?
Ich promoviere in Physik, in theoretischer Physik, und bin da halt mit Computerprogrammen beschäftigt, allerdings nur Fortran 77, weil wir halt Number Crunching machen. Number Crunching. Wir rechnen sehr viel, ohne da besonders komplizierte Programme für zu benutzen, und da ist Fortran immer ein Vorteil. Mein Programm läuft im Moment auf Workstations, aber ich habe halt auch schon auf Parallelrechnungen gearbeitet, T3D und CM5, CM2 und so weiter. Es gibt auch in meinem Institut Leute, die rechnen auf einem Spezialparallelrechner, APE heißt der, den werdet ihr wahrscheinlich nicht kennen will.
Können wir bei euch vielleicht mal ein paar Deskodes berechnen? Wir hätten doch noch diesen Poolschlüssel in Auftrag zu geben für die EC-Karten.
Sag mal, wenn du mit der Connection Machine gearbeitet hast, es gibt da widersprechende Gerüchte, wie schnell die nun ist. Hast du den Eindruck, die performt im Vergleich zu einer T3D?
Die ist natürlich langsamer als eine T3D, aber man muss auch einfach gucken, wann die TM5 rausgekommen ist. Die war zu ihrer Zeit, als die entwickelt worden ist und marktgeschmissen worden ist, einfach super gut. Die T3D ist ein paar Jahre später auf den Markt gekommen und konnte dann eben auch die Technologie, die es in den Jahren weiterentwickelt hat, anwenden und war dann entsprechend auch schneller. Oder ist sie immer noch? Ich meine, das T3E ist ja...
Ich wurde gerade darauf hingewiesen. Es handelt sich bei der T3D um eine Maschine der Firma Cray. Und ich glaube, die hier in Berlin steht, hat 192 DEC-Alpha-Prozessoren, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Das ist supergenial.
Also ich halte von der Maschine nicht so besonders viel. Die ist halt in ihrer Technologie eher so als Monster gebaut. Und das war die CM5 nicht.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass die T3D wesentlich hübscher aussieht? Das sind doch diese blauen Blüten.
Die CM5 ist designt worden. Obwohl, ich könnte jetzt noch eine kleine Geschichte zu den LEDs, die dort ablassen.
Ja, das Wichtigste.
Das wird dann doch ein bisschen wahr.
Wir wollen doch mal was lernen.
Bei der CM2, da konnte man die LEDs, die da draußen waren, durch das Programmieren der Maschine, in bestimmte Zustände bringen. Man konnte also da quasi ablesen, was für ein Pro, oder wie das Programm gerade was macht. Und auf der CM5, da waren halt auch viele LEDs dran, aber da geht das leider nicht mehr. Da sind ja unabhängig von dem Prozessor-Status gesteuert. Das ist natürlich ein deutliches Manko der CM5.
Sag mal, du hast ja eigentlich immer...
Eine gute Methode, um Daten rauszuschmuggeln, so Stigonographie auf...
Sag mal, wenn ihr so zu Hause sitzt, abends, oder beim Bier in der Kneipe, habt ihr immer Gesprächsthemen, wo ihr gleich massig Leute mit einbinden könnt. Ihr könnt ja den ganzen Abend gestalten. Unglaublich. Da lernt man auch eine Menge Frauen kennen bestimmt, oder? Ja, aber mehr Männer lernst du damit auch nicht kennen, oder? Ich würde sagen, da gehört die Geschlechtsspezifische nicht unbedingt. Ich glaube, dass es nur wenig Leute gibt, die sich damit wirklich auskennen, um mitdiskutieren zu können.
Also beim Club Dienstag sitzen immer nur Männer. Ich finde das auch komisch.
Nicht nur Männer. Gar nicht wahr. Wir haben doch gar nichts.
Ja klar, das war auch alles ein bisschen augenzwinkern gemeint. Ich finde auch das Schönste an dieser Sendung, die übrigens einmal im Monat stattfindet, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Das Schönste ist, dass ich mir mal vorstelle, wenn hier jemand zufällig einschaltet, dann merkt er, was passiert und worüber reden die? Ist doch irgendwas passiert in der Zwischenzeit. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank erstmal. Und wir haben was gelernt, du hast was gelernt. So soll das auch sein.
Bis dann.
Und jetzt sind hier auch noch einige mehr Anrufer.
Gibt es noch Mods oder sowas?
Ohne Ende.
War mal.
Was Kurzes? Das Kurze hab ich nicht mehr. Ich hab nur was Langes. Machen wir gleich.
Machen wir gleich. Erst mal ein bisschen weiter telefonieren. Hi, wer ist denn da? Hallo? Hallo. Ah, schau, verpasst. Tja, da muss man schnell sein. Multitasking ist gefragt. Hallo?
Hallo.
Ah, siehst du so. Wer bist du denn?
Ich bin Holger, hallo.
Holger, hi.
Also ich wollte ganz gerne fragen, wie viele seid ihr da im Studio? Zwei? Zwei richtige Experten?
Drei. Drei Experten und ich.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal nachfragen, was ihr drei bzw. vier dem T-Online für eine Zukunft widmet.
In welcher Hinsicht?
Was Kitt und Zept etc. anbelangt.
Also das wird sterben. Ja, aber T-Online wird nicht sterben. Die schalten das ja auf 0-1-3-0 irgendwie. Oder haben zumindest derartige Planung.
Die werden aber auch massiv aufrüsten.
Die haben massiv Bannung. Also die haben da schon einiges vor, aber nicht mit diesen alten Standards.
Das ist klar.
Also es geht alles voll in Richtung Internet.
Und was glaubt ihr, was machen die Unternehmen, die jetzt auf Kit und Zip gesetzt haben?
Na, entweder sterben oder Java und ähnliches.
Also ganz schwer davon rausgehen, dass der einzige Standard, der sich durchsetzen wird, die Internet-Standards.
Das bringt uns mal wieder zum Thema, nämlich Java. Es gibt ein recht interessantes Java-Applet. Und zwar ist es das Applet der Firma Brocard. Das dient dazu, Finanztransaktionen über das Internet zu machen, und zwar verschlüsselt. Das Ganze läuft so, dass ein Java-Applet über eine verschlüsselte Leitung in Netscape reingeladen wird, über diese International Security von Netscape. Und das Applet beinhaltet selber nochmal kryptografische Software, die wiederum eine zweite verschlüsselte Verbindung auf der verschlüsselten Verbindung macht. Dadurch wird das Ganze auch mit einer verkrüppelten Version von Netscape nicht besonders leicht angreifbar. Gibt ja auch da natürlich Schwachstellen. Und gerade diese Technologie ist in der Lage, KIT und Z ein bisschen in den Rang abzulaufen.
Also das ist der sogenannte SSL, um es vielleicht nochmal kurz hineinzubringen.
Na ja, zur Zeit läuft ja dieser T-Online-Anbieter-Tag oder so. Habt ihr da so ein bisschen mal recherchiert?
Was meinst du heute, diese Internet-World hier in Berlin?
Sieht auch da ja.
Eingeschlafene Füße.
Also da war ich, das meinst du aber jetzt nicht die Internet-World.
Nein, das mein ich nicht. Es ist irgendwie so ein, der nennt sich T-Online-Anbieter-Tag.
Das ist glaube ich parallel dazu, ne?
Möglicherweise, ja.
Da wissen wir nichts drüber. Die werden denen wahrscheinlich nur erzählen, dass sie sich darauf einrichten sollen, dass Zapp und Kitt nicht weitergemacht werden in absehbarer Zukunft. Sie sollen schon mal anfangen, HTML zu programmieren. Ich meine, da tun die meisten sowieso, bzw. die Agenturen, die Firmen, die ja meist für die anderen Firmen die Software erstellt haben, die sind unter Garantie auch schon im Internet platziert, sonst könnten die gar nicht überleben. Von daher ist das eine ganz natürliche Transition. Es werden natürlich die alten Dienste noch eine Weile gefahren werden, weil es auch Leute gibt, die jetzt nur keinen Bock haben, irgendwie davon abzurücken, gerade Homebanking. Aber gerade zu den multimedialen Dinger, da kann man sich ja in T-Online auch nicht konkurrenzfähig halten. Man kann ja mit dem, was mit Java und diesen ganzen anderen Sachen im Internet mittlerweile geleistet wird, einfach überhaupt nicht mehr reell mit Schritt halten und deswegen wird es zwangsläufig sterben. Telekom hat gar kein Interesse daran, da noch eine eigene Technologie hochzuhalten. Die wollen eigentlich nur ihre Leitungen verkaufen, und das tun sie sehr viel besser mit Internet und Telefonie. Und sind vielleicht auch ganz froh, dass das Problem BTX als solches dann mittelfristig auch loswerden.
Also ich bin da nicht so sehr bewandert, aber mich würde interessieren, der große Vorteil an T-Online bzw. an diesen Kit- und Z-Geschichten ist doch, dass da der Sicherheitsstandard relativ hoch ist.
Nein, erst mal nicht.
Oder es liegt eher am Netz.
Die Sicherheitsprobleme sind erst mal nicht so hoch.
Da wo man das liegt, aber klar, am Netz, es liegt daran, dass es sich in Anführungszeichen um ein geschlossenes Netz, das ja auf Mainframes basiert, also um einen Online-Dienst handelt und eben nicht um ein Internet, das auf einem Protokoll basiert, das von sich aus schon mal Schwächen aufweist, wie eben Spoofing, also Wörttäuschen von Adressinformationen, Auslesen von Datenpaketen, Sneefing und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist im Grunde genommen der Sicherheitsvorteil von BTX, weswegen da Homebanking klassischerweise eben die Applikation drauf war. Mit Abrechnungen. Ja, wer will denn heutzutage noch bezahlen? Ich meine, Internet ist ja nun...
Das wird auch im Internet kommen, also das ist...
Ja, aber jetzt für Applikation oder für Bandbreite.
Ich denke, das Modell Zahlen für Seiten wird ein bisschen sterben, sondern Zahlen wird man für die konkreten Dienstleistungen. Das Internet ist nur der Transportweg, auf dem diese Dienstleistungen verkauft werden. Das heißt, es wird mehr dahingehend zu Einzelzahlungen, gezielten Zahlungen, eben wie es heute stattfindet mit Kreditkarten oder mit solchen automatischen Zahlungssystemen wie dem First Virtual oder vergleichbaren Systemen. Das ist so eine Art virtuelle Bankro, wo du dich einmal registrierst und du gibst nur noch dein First Virtual-Konto-Nummer sozusagen an. Davon wird es abgebucht und indirekt von hinten wird es über deine Kreditkarte dann letztlich auch tatsächlich abgebucht. Und wie gesagt, das ist alles nur eine Frage der Zeit. Man muss es auch so sehen, T-Online gibt es wirklich nur in Deutschland und der ganze Rest der Welt braucht auf dem Internet all diese Funktionalitäten. AOL ist sicherlich auch noch ein Konkurrent, ist auch der einzige, der sich derzeit überhaupt noch gegenüber dem Internet behaupten kann. CompuSurf hat es ja mittlerweile sein lassen. Die haben gesagt, das Ende jetzt, Schluss aus, vorbei, wir machen nur noch Internet. Und migrieren jetzt ihren ganzen Kram noch ins Netz rein und versuchen noch zu retten, was für sie zu retten ist. Das ist nicht mehr so sehr viel. AOL ist relativ erfolgreich, weil sie schon immer sehr von vornherein die Privatkunden angegangen sind und jetzt halt im Kombieangebot auch noch Internet mit verschärbeln. Sie werden sich über einen kurzen Erlang natürlich auch zum reinen Internet-Service-Provider entwickeln und mit solchen Technologien wie Java. Zum Beispiel kann man nämlich auch die alten Oberflächen, die in AOL noch so drin sind, übrigens, was ähnliches könnte man auch bei BTX machen, dass man mit Java sozusagen innerhalb von Internetbrausern einfach genau dasselbe ZAP-User-Interface bzw. AOL-User-Interface oder auch CompuServe-User-Interface mit reinbringt, dass sie sich genauso benutzen, dass die eigentliche Netzstruktur vollkommen wegfällt. Das hat man noch gar nicht beleuchtet. Das ist wirklich auch noch ein wichtiger Punkt von Java, dass man in beliebige Oberflächen ja auch nachbauen kann.
Okay, das war's.
Heuer, war's das?
Das war's.
Okay, danke dir.
Weil eigentlich sollten wir uns jetzt an mir nicht mal den dunklen Seiten des Lebens widmen.
Wollen wir zuerst mal ein bisschen Musik spielen?
Was haltet ihr da von mir? Wir haben hier noch ein nettes Mod auf Lager.
Ist von Herrn Internet.
Scheiß Liga schon moderner, du.
Wie gesagt, das sind Mods von euch eingeschickt. Hörer machen Musik fürs Chaos Radio. Auf Amiga-Rechnern wahrscheinlich dann dem nach entstanden. Hast du dir einen Titel dabei, wie die Nummer heißt? Nein, ne?
Dann Arex.
Arex?
Ja, das ist auch sehr verbreitet im Netz. Also ich denke mal nicht, dass es der Hörer selbst gemacht hat, das war jetzt nur irgendwie eine gute Selektion.
Jetzt rufen natürlich hier noch ganz viele Leute an, aber lasst uns mit demnächst erstmal zum ActiveX Hack kommen. Eine interessante Geschichte, vor allen Dingen auch für alle im Moment noch Nicht-Computer-Anwender, denn das Homebanking, was es ja jetzt schon gibt, wird euch auch erwischen und zwar unaufhaltsam. Hier im Blumund-Chat unter www.fritz.de slash Speakers slash Chat ging es auch gerade um die Postbank, die angeblich demnächst dann im Internet Homebanking anbieten will. Da werden wir dann noch einiges wahrscheinlich drüber hören gleich. Aber das wird eine interessante Geschichte, die wir gleich machen.
Die neue Internetstrategie von Microsoft dreht sich vor allem um ein Buzzword, ActiveX. Dahinter verbirgt sich eigentlich ein alter Bekannter, das Object Linking and Embedding, OLE, und das Component Object Model, COM, das auch schon in den bisherigen Windows Versionen auftauchte. ActiveX ist die Internetvariante dieser Technologien. Kurz zusammengefasst macht ActiveX folgendes. Ist ein Stück Code auf einem Rechner noch nicht installiert, so wird es über TCPIP in den Rechner hinein geladen, wie das sonst von der Festplatte erfolgen würde. ActiveX Code ist letztlich nichts anderes als die alte, bekannte DLL an der Dynamic Links Library. Microsoft bricht schrittweise sein Betriebssystem und seine Anwendungen in diese DLLs auf, wogegen eigentlich nichts einzuwenden ist. Der Einsatz von ActiveX wiederum stößt aber auf ein massives Problem im Internet, die Sicherheit. Wird ein ActiveX Control, so heißen die Internet DLLs dann, vom Netz in den Rechner geladen, wird das danach sofort ausgeführt. Da es sich dabei um normalen Windows-Code handelt, kann das Software-Modul sofort auf alle Ressourcen des Rechners einschließlich des Dateisystems und der installierten Programme zugreifen. Modifikationen von Dateien, Programmen oder gar des Betriebssystems selber stellen eine akute Gefahr dar und auch ein Absturz des Programmteils ist nicht auszuschließen. Angesichts der teilweise miesen Qualität der Beta-Software des Internets ist dies auch ein Horrorszenario der Zukunft. Der Chaos Computer Club zeigte vor ein paar Monaten, wie ActiveX elegant zum Angriff auf die heimischen Datenbestände missbraucht werden kann. Ein Beispiel ActiveX Control wurde in eine Webseite eingebettet, sodass es beim Betrachten durch einen Windows-Rechner mit dem Webbrowser Microsoft Internet Explorer sofort heruntergeladen und ausgeführt wurde. Dort tat das Programm das Unerwartete. Es schaute auf der lokalen Festplatte gezielt nach dem Programm Quicken von der Firma Intuit, eines der meistverkauften Programme für private Kassenführung und Homebanking. Als dies gefunden wurde, wurde es gestartet und per OLE angewiesen, eine neue Überweisung in seine Auftragsdatei einzufügen, die beim nächsten Kontakt mit dem Rechner der Bank auch ausgeführt werden würde. Der Benutzer merkte von all dem nichts. Er sah nur, dass sich eine Webseite aufbaute. Im besten Fall registrierte er noch das leichte Rappeln der Festplatte. Doch auch das ist ja nichts Besonderes, wenn man mit einem Webbrowser arbeitet. Intuit, der Hersteller von Quicken, und Microsoft waren aus dem Häuschen. Während aber Intuit schlicht vor der Benutzung des Internet-Explorers abriet, dementierte Microsoft zunächst einmal alles. Es gäbe ja den Authenticode-Mechanismus, der überprüfen könnte, ob das geladene Kontroll auch vertrauenswürdig sei. Diese Feststellung war wieder richtig, noch trägt sie dazu bei, ActiveX sicherer zu machen. Eine Überwachung des Codes zur Laufzeit, wie Java es vorsieht, ist mit ActiveX schlicht nicht möglich.
Ich versuche das nochmal für alle ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, warum es bei diesem ActiveX Hack ging. Wenn ihr eine bestimmte Seite im Internet angewählt habt, und das war ungünstigerweise die, auf der dieser Hack stattfand, dieses Experiment, möchte ich es mal nennen, von Chaos Computer Club, und ihr habt Quicken auf eurem Windows-Rechner, dann hat unbemerkt dieses Programm, während ihr im Netz surft, dafür gesorgt, dass es eine Überweisung von, gab es da eine Summe, 20 Mark oder so?
Nein, das stand nicht im Internet, sondern es ist nur für die Panoramasendung festweise aufgesetzt. Aber es wäre trotzdem eine Summe. Aber es könnte genauso auch im Netz stehen. Das ist ja das, worauf ihr hinweist.
Also für diese Sendung wurde das gemacht. Man wählt diese Seite an und dann wird eine Überweisung auf mein Konto gestartet, unmerklich, unter Windows, in Quicken. Und wenn ihr dann das nächste Mal euren Kontostand überprüfen wolltet, wurde diese Überweisung klammheimlich abgeschickt. Und die, was immer, welche Summe, wird an mich dann in diesem Fall natürlich immer an mich. Das lässt sich nur auf mein Konto üben.
Das lässt sich auch nicht dementieren.
Aber um zunächst mal klarzumachen, worum es geht, es geht nicht um die Unsicherheit einer Homebanking-Software. Also das war das Problem in der Presseberichterstatt. Und dann zum Beispiel diese Leute von Plusminus, die Fernsehredakteure, die es gebracht haben, die haben da die ganze Zeit immer nur von Homebanking geredet und ActiveX nicht einmal erwähnt, weil sie irgendwie Angst vor Microsoft hatten. Der Microsoft-Presse-Sprecher hatte nachmittags angerufen, später die Anwälte und dann hatten sie erst mal die Hosen oftmals gestrichen voll. Es geht also einfach darum, dass der Computer dann mit ActiveX vollständig fernsteuerbar ist. Das ist auch so geplant. Es handelt sich also nicht um einen Fehler, um einen Bug im Microsoft-Konzept, sondern in der Ausführung, sondern im Konzept selbst. Also ActiveX für sich ist sozusagen der Fehler. Es hat keinen Fehler, sondern es ist der Fehler. Und die versuchen sozusagen diese Fernsteuerbarkeit des Computers mit etwas wegzumachen, was sich Software-Authentifizierung nennt. Das bedeutet, anders als bei der sozusagen ersten Version von Java, mittlerweile gibt es das bei Java aus, auch ist es so, dass ActiveX-Controlls, wie sie heißen, vom Netz zwar mehr oder weniger überall geladen werden können, aber diese Controls eine Signatur haben. Also sozusagen mitliefern, wer der Autor davon ist. Und es sind da sozusagen Mechanismen drin über dann Zertifizierungsinstanzen, die mir also als Autor sozusagen die Möglichkeit geben, mein Programm, ich lasse mich amtlich als Softwareproduzent registrieren, lege da meinen Personalausweis und 20 Dollar auf den Tisch und dann habe ich eine elektronische Signatur, mit der der Benutzer sozusagen nachvollziehen kann, aha, dieses Programm ist von irgendwie Dagobert Druck geschrieben. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass der Benutzer weiß, was das Programm tut. Er kann vielleicht eine Beschreibung lesen, er kann mir dann glauben, was mein Programm tut oder nicht, er kann es allerdings letztendlich nicht steuern und das ist sozusagen der Trick.
Du hast doch auch so einen Code, den man kriegt, als eingetragener Programmierer, den kann man sich ja wahrscheinlich auch gefaktet dann irgendwie mal besorgen, also so wie man sich auch falsche E-Mail-Adressen besorgen kann.
Gut, ich meine, vom Konzept her ist das erst mal eine Idee. Da gibt es schon, also über die kryptographischen Verfahren, die letztendlich benutzt werden, kann man da schon von einer einigermaßen Verlässlichkeit reden, davon, dass der Autor dann auch tatsächlich da ist. Bloß, dass ein ActiveX-Control es dann erst mal durchgeflusht hat, dass man halt alles tun kann, zum Beispiel die Abzenderinformation wieder löschen oder eben die Festplatte gleich komplett löschen oder irgendwie so etwas. Es gibt also keine Sicherheitsarchitektur wie bei Java. Dazu vielleicht, vielleicht magst du dazu noch kurz was sagen, Andreas, also dass eben bei Java es da zunächst einmal Restriktionen gibt auf das, was so ein Java-Programm dann letztendlich tun darf. In der ersten Version war das Bildschirm und das der Zugriff.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch ein bisschen was über das Authentico erzählen.
Warte mal, lass uns damit kurz noch mal nach dem Fritz-Info anfangen, weil wir gleich in einer guten Rhythmus Kurz-Info haben.
Das sind doch noch 60 Sekunden.
Na gut, dann schaffst du das sowieso nicht in 60 Sekunden. Nein, spür mir sie.
Der ist nur noch 50.
Hast du noch einen Mod?
Ja, ich mach mal doch ein bisschen was Fetziges.
Fax schreibt übrigens, ob ihr den Beavis und Butthead Mod mit habt, den er euch geschickt hat. Der ist nämlich von ihm selber.
Hast du den?
Nein, einige Mods hab ich auch nicht lesen können. Das Problem ist, ich mach immer alles mit dem Mac und muss mir erst mal akribisch alle Treckerprogramme zusammensuchen, um die alle abspielen zu können, weil es ja so viele unterschiedliche Formate gibt. Ein paar Sachen waren auch korrupt. Mir ist auch eine Diskette zugeschickt worden von jemandem. Da war auch nur einer zu lesen. Wir bedanken uns trotzdem sehr für die Diskette.
Das andere Fall werden wir nachher bestimmt noch spielen. Fax sagt hier gerade, das waren drei Mails. Ich weiß nicht, ob er die auch gerade erst geschickt hat. Egal, das werden wir dann in der nächsten Sendung nachhören. Super, Windows, echt ein tolles System. Wir haben uns übrigens auch das Problem mit dem Mod hier geklärt von Fax. Das ist tatsächlich gerade erst per E-Mail gekommen. So schnell sind wir natürlich nicht, Leute. Also wenn ihr uns Mods schickt oder andere Soundfiles, wenn ihr auf, weiß ich nicht, AIFs, keine Ahnung, wenn ihr zu Hause bastelt, Sounds, wenn ihr Geschichten schreibt, schickt uns die auch an chaos.orb.de. Wenn ihr witzige Bilder macht zum Thema oder schickt uns aber bitte keinen Müll, dann schickt uns das alles zu chaos.orb.de. Und wenn ihr jetzt gerade erst eine E-Mail geschickt habt, wo irgendein Mod dranhängt, dann können wir das natürlich nicht gleich abspielen. Die beste Reaktion bisher hatte übrigens mein Rumhacken hier auf der Tastatur, dieses wunderbare Umrechner hier. So ein Chat hier neben sich zu haben, ist lustig, wenn man den dabei beobachten kann. Das ist Chaos Radio, den Computertemun bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Icke. Also das Verhalten im Chat ist nicht anders als bei Anrufen. Es gibt Anrufer, die wollen einfach nur kurz mal durchkommen. Und dann gibt es auch Chatter, die wollen einfach nur, dass ihr Name mal im Radio erwähnt wird. Komm, sag ich mal vorlesen, wer jetzt gerade hier im Chat ist. Java, Fragezeichen.
The Fox ist da.
Fax ist da. Todd ist glaube ich schon draußen. Eurer sagt nichts mehr. Dann WD. Ist doch einiges los. Schön. Haben sie aber auch schon einige wieder verabschiedet. Und wenn durch neue ersetzt. Toll, funktioniert. Das ist eine Beta-Software, die hier läuft. Im fritz.ww.w. fritz.de slash speakers slash chats. Da könnt ihr heute mal ein bisschen rumspielen. Und ja, ich hab euch doch alle gegrüßt, die Zippen hier und vieles weise grüßen. Ihr müsst da jetzt fachmännisch diskutieren. Im Chat. Ihr müsst jetzt da ganz technisch werden. Nein, müsst ihr nicht. Ein Song von Andi ausgewählt, der ihn Lin widmen möchte. Wir reden über Java, wir reden über ActiveX, wir haben gerade eine Einführung von Tim zu ActiveX gehört, was das überhaupt ist und warum nicht der Fehler bei ActiveX liegt, sondern warum ActiveX der Fehler ist. Wir haben über den ActiveX Hack des Chaos Computer Clubs ein bisschen was gehört und werden darüber jetzt auch noch ein bisschen mehr hören.
Ja, also im Prinzip ist ja dieses Authenticode gar keine so schlechte Idee. Es reicht natürlich nicht aus, man braucht natürlich noch andere Möglichkeiten zu verhindern, dass das Programm schlimme Sachen mit dem Computer anstellt, aber in der Softwareindustrie, vor allen Dingen im Internet, ist es schon seit ein Jahr Zeit üblich, die Software signiert auszuliefern, und zwar wird dazu auch schon seit Jahren. PGP verwendet es also mitnichten, so wie Microsoft behauptet, dass dieses Authenticode etwas Neues wäre, aber der große Unterschied zwischen Authenticode und PGP-Signaturen oft tarfalls ist der, dass man eine Authenticode-Unterschrift nur von Microsoft bekommt, und zwar in Formen der Firma VeriSign. Also es ist uns nicht gelungen, auf irgendeine andere Art und Weise einen Key zu erzeugen, das soll zwar alles stannisiert sein, ist aber nicht so, und einen solchen Key, mit dem man seine Software unterschreiben kann, bekommt man auch nur als Bürger der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika. Das heißt, es wird Gang und Gebe sein, dass im Netz unsignierte Controls herumliegen, denn wenn man eine in Europa erstellte Kontroll zertifizieren will, so geht das derzeit nicht.
Aber man muss sich das dann zertifizieren?
Ja, das hat auch mit dem Marketingkonzept zu tun, weil Microsoft eben sagt, wir haben zwar keine Sicherheit, und das geht dafür bei uns alle schneller, dafür haben wir eben diese Authentifizierung. Und im Prinzip ist es so, dass Microsoft sozusagen Lizenzen an diejenigen vergibt, die überhaupt in der Lage sind, die Befugnis haben, ActiveX-Controls zu schreiben. Das ist zunächst einmal auf der Metaebene diese Instanz VeriSign. Das ist eine Firma in Amerika, die eben als Zertifizierungsinstanz von Microsoft eine Lizenz hat und wiederum von sich aus an die Programmierer dann letztendlich gegen Gebühr, versteht sich, eben ein solches Zertifikat sozusagen verkauft.
Aber nützt dann sowas überhaupt? Also wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt weiß, jemand ist da eingetragen, da ActiveX-Schreiber bei Microsoft hat die Lizenz, hat diese Zertifizierung und ich kann an seinen Rechner, dann kann ich das Ding doch klauen und unter seinen Namen was machen.
Nein, jeder Terrorist kann sich so ein Ding holen. Das ist überhaupt nicht die Frage. Das ist keine Sicherheit. Es ist lediglich, die gehen halt davon aus, man vertraut einem Programmierer und dieser Programmierer, der darf dann mit seinem Computer machen, was man will. Weil die meisten Leute, die sich ein Windows-PC hingestellt haben, die vertrauen ja ohnehin schon Microsoft und vertrauen auch mal ohnehin schon drauf.
Na ja, das ist noch ein bisschen was anderes. Ich meine, es gibt ja durchaus Programmierer, denen man vertrauen kann, wenn das alles im Source-Code vorliegt und unabhängige andere Instanzen geprüft haben, dass es alles in Ordnung ist. Dann kann man sich schon eine Reputation schaffen. Und von gewissen Leuten würde ich Programme einfach bedenkenlos auf meinem Rechner starten und tue das auch jeden Tag. Das Problem mit Authenticode ist, dass nur Microsoft sagt, wer das überhaupt benutzen darf und dass es nicht mal so sicher ist, dass ich mich darauf verlassen kann. Also jeder, der eine Social Security-Number und die Wohnadresse eines Amerikaners kennt und vielleicht auch noch weiß, wie die Kreditkartenchecksum berechnet werden, kann sich so ein Authenticode-Key holen, ohne dafür Geld bezahlen zu müssen, indem er da einfach Daten von irgendjemand in ein Webformular einträgt. Also konkret, es wird Sicherheit vorgespielt und eigentlich ist dieses Authenticode ein Marketing-Kontrollinstrument von Microsoft.
Ja, ja, mach ich gleich. Ja.
Sind wir auf Sendung? Ich will auch.
Aber ich habe vergessen, Fake zu grüßen, Entschuldige-Fake. Mann ey. Ja, jetzt rufen wir nämlich Lutz mal an. Weil Lutz hat auch noch einiges dazu zu sagen. Wir haben ein Telefon-Interview im Chaos-Radio. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich einen zu pögel, sonst gehe ich.
Rata, rata, rata, rata, rata.
Also, Lutz Donahack ist einer derjenigen, die sozusagen diese Vorführung im Fernsehbeitrag gemacht haben.
Ach so.
Und deswegen wollten wir ihn jetzt auch anrufen und da sozusagen von ihm aus noch mal ein paar Sachen hören, was denn da eigentlich die Intention, das Ergebnis, die Reaktion und der weitere Plan auf der Absuchung ist.
Press 1, if you like Johnny.
Solltest du den Regler runterziehen? Ich glaube nicht, dass er begeistert ist, dass gerade so ein Telefonnummer ist.
Ihr habt das jetzt nicht gehört.
So, Lutz ist am Apparat und den könnt ihr jetzt anständig vorstellen. Hallo Lutz. Wunderbar, du klingst ganz großartig. Was ist das denn für eine Telefonanlage? Nein, egal, war keine ernsthafte Frage.
Lutz, das ist eine ernsthafte Frage. Ich habe extra einen anderen Apparat geholt.
Ach guck an, extra für diese Sendung?
Ja natürlich, normalerweise habe ich ein Kohle-Mikro.
Man muss dazu sagen, Lutz sitzt sozusagen im finsteren Osten, wenn ich das irgendwie so frei sagen darf. Aber noch mal kurz zu ActiveX-Hack selbst. Wir haben jetzt ein bisschen erklärt für dich nochmal, du hast die Sendung jetzt nicht verfolgt, irgendwie was Java überhaupt ist, was ActiveX ist, vom Konzept hier, von der Sicherheitsproblematik. Und dieser Hack hat ja zunächst einmal irgendwie zwei Themen betroffen. Nämlich einmal diese Systemarchitektur, Streitereien, ActiveX, Java und zum anderen das Homeping. Was war dann irgendwie die Intention, ursprünglich mit dem Fernsehbeitrag da sozusagen zu erreichen? In welche Kerbe sollte es dann hauen?
Das ist eine ganz blöde Frage, weil eigentlich haben wir ja angefangen einfach nur blöd zu quatschen und dann rumzuwetten, ob das denn überhaupt geht. Und siehe an, es funktioniert tatsächlich. Im Endeffekt ging es um einen Angriff Nulls Ordnung, also einen Angriff gegen den Rechner, gegen das Betriebssystem selbst. Dass uns gerade Homeping erwischt hatte, das war nun einfach an der Zusammensetzung des Tisches, als das erste Mal darüber gesprochen wurde.
Nee, klar, aber hatte das denn letztendlich vom Ergebnis nicht auch was mit dem Unverständnis der beteiligten Redakteure zu tun, die daraus ja am Grunde genommen Homebanking ist unsicher gemacht haben und nicht ActiveX ist unsicher?
Das lag wahrscheinlich mehr daran, dass die ja schon vorgeprägt kamen. Die hatten ja schon im Winterkopf, wir müssen was mit Homebanking machen und ich habe nur noch drei Wochen Zeit und so in der Größenordnung. Also im Prinzip schon das Thema vorneweg gesetzt hatten und dann nur noch gesehen haben, was reinpasst, das übliche Verfahren. Immer wenn man eine Arbeit sehr schnell fertig machen muss, dann werden alle Probleme zu einem Nagelsummer in den Hammer hat.
Ja, also auf gut Deutsch, die haben euch sozusagen in etwas hineingeschraubt, was sie ohnehin geplant hatten. Aber trotzdem hat der Beitrag dann ja einjermaßen reingehauen und es gab ja, sagen wir kurz und mittelfristig, etliche Reaktionen auch von den betroffenen Unternehmen, Microsoft und Intuit. Vielleicht magst du ein paar Worte dazu sagen, wie sozusagen dich jetzt als einer der Produzenten der Geschichte, wie dich da die Reaktionen erreicht haben.
Die ersten Reaktionen, die gab es ganz normal über die Webseiten, da hat man eben gesehen, dass sich da irgendjemand Gedanken macht. Nur in dem Vorfeld, also das heißt, während der Dreharbeiten kündigte Microsoft an, dass sie genau die Sache, die wir als Hektar verkauft haben, mit Quicken zusammen als neue Bezahlungsweise über Internet ablaufen lassen möchte. Da haben wir natürlich herzlich gelacht. Aber die eigentlichen Reaktionen waren dann, dass das Telefon klingelte und hieß, Hallihallo, hier ist Reporter so und so und ich habe ein Problem, angeblich ist Homebanking unsicher, erklär mal. Das andere waren die ganzen Geschichten über E-Mail, die im Endeffekt nur noch über einen Autoresponsor zu erledigen waren, also über einen Automaten. Ansonsten keine Chance mehr. Das größte Problem, was wir dabei hatten, war sicherlich die Firma Microsoft selbst, weil die deutsche Zentrale Schlichtenagrafen keine Ahnung hatte, was eigentlich passiert war. Und die Amerikaner eigentlich wissen wollten, was in Deutschland los war und die konnten es ihnen nicht sagen. Die Konsequenz daraus war eigentlich, dass, sagen wir mal so, sehr lustige Beiträge für die Presse rausgekommen sind, weil die nämlich nicht gewusst haben, was sie antworten sollen und schließlich und ergreifend nur unflädig geworden sind. Das war die eine Sache, die hat die Presse sich natürlich wahnsinnig darüber gefreut und die andere Geschichte ist dann gewesen, dass wir sehr, sehr schnell an den Spiegel gekommen sind, was sich im Nachhinein als einer der größeren Fehler in der Pressearbeit herausgestellt hat. Warum? Microsoft hat sich auf der C-Pit nochmal explizit dafür bedankt, dass wir bereits in der zweiten Woche den Spiegelartikel hatten. Weil die Wahl einen Spiegelartikel zu irgendeinem Thema verhindert, dass irgendeine Wirtschaftszeitung in niederer Art, die irgendwelche Manager erreichen könnte, irgendetwas noch dazu bringt.
Wieso ist das so?
Das scheint in den Redaktionsköpfen so drinnen zu sein. Wenn die Spiegel etwas gebracht hat, dann schreiben wir nicht mehr.
Das hängt auch mit dem Exklusivitätswahn des Spiegels zusammen. Das kenn ich auch. Wenn du mit denen über eine Geschichte redest, dann wollen die die unbedingt exklusiv haben. Da darf kein anderer Journalist etwas davon erfahren. Das ist sozusagen deren Corporate Identity. Was mich interessiert, es gab gezielt eine Desinformationskampagne von Seiten Microsoft, kann man sagen, was die Betroffenheit von ActiveX in dem Spiel betrifft.
Microsoft USA hatte ein sehr leichtes Spiel. Es gab kaum Informationen in den USA, was überhaupt passiert war. Es gab im Endeffekt nur die Information, dass mithilfe von Quicken und ActiveX irgendetwas passiert ist, wo Konten geplündert werden können. Microsoft hat dann mit der entsprechenden Medienmacht, die sie sich dazu gekauft haben, in den USA den gesamten Februar über ziemlich ungestört verbreitet, dass das ein Fehler von Quicken ist, schlicht die Firma Intuit ist haftbar zu machen. Die waren nach dem Februar so ziemlich fertig, dass die einige Millionen Verluste eingesteckt hatten im Verkauf.
Na gut, das war ja letztendlich auch die Reaktion der GIMA, was wir hier erlebt haben, dass das zu einer internationalen Diskussion über ActiveX geführt hat. Trotzdem kann man jetzt wohl noch nicht sagen, dass ActiveX weg vom Fenster ist. Wie schätzt du, wie hart hat das dieses Projekt geschlagen?
Das Schönste ist, dass man heutzutage wirklich bei einer beliebigen Waschblätter der Computerpresse aufschlagen darf und praktisch auf jeden zweiten und dritten Artikel die Meinung liest, dass man alles machen darf, nur nicht mit ActiveX. Der ganze Presserummel hat zumindest bewirkt, dass alles, was in irgendeiner Form sich Computerzeitungsredaktion nennt, weiß, dass ActiveX etwas Böses ist und dass der Kunde davor zu beschützen ist. Die meisten Kunden wissen es auch.
Und das fühlst du auch auf diese Aktion zurück? Was fühlst du auch auf diese Aktion zurück? Ich habe jetzt eine Frage, die ein bisschen ins Allgemeinere geht. Ich hatte gehofft, dass hier die Jungs, die vor Ort sind, dich ein bisschen einführen und vorstellen, was du überhaupt machst. Wir wissen nur, du heißt Lutz und du bist jetzt am Telefon. Aber das können wir gleich noch ein bisschen klären. Aber wenn ihr so Pressearbeit macht, wenn ihr an breite Medien geht mit solchen Geschichten, die ihr rausgefunden habt oder die ihr aufgedeckt habt, die ihr recherchiert habt, habt ihr dann nicht sowieso das Problem, dass ihr natürlich auf Journalisten oft stoßt, die eigentlich mehr Interesse an irgendeiner guten oder witzigen Geschichte haben, also die dann dieses ActiveX-Ding zu einem reinen Homebanking-Problem machen und die genauso wenig wie Boulevardblättern Interesse daran haben, eine wirkliche Aufklärung zu betreiben, was sie vielleicht auch gar nicht selber verstehen?
Ja, das ist normal. Ich meine, Journalisten haben natürlich ein eigenes Interesse, sich selbst wichtig zu machen, möglichst große, sensationelle Geschichten.
Ich finde, wir sollten mal eine Sendung über Veränderung der Medien... Aus welchem Grund?
Das können wir nicht.
Das verkraften die Leute.
Lutz, wir fahren dich. Wir zahlen dir ein Bahnticket, dann kannst du her.
Aber eine Frage habe ich ja trotzdem noch auf dem Zettel. Ich meine, Java weicht jetzt ihre Sandbox, wie sie sie nennen, also ihre Sicherheitsarchitektur auch auf. Wie problematisch ist denn das perspektivisch gesehen? Was kommt da an Unsicherheit konkret Möglichkeiten denn dazu?
Es wird ähnlich passieren, wie das bei allen Aufweichungen in Richtung Sicherheitsumgebung passiert, dass nämlich jeder Nutzer möglichst weiträumig sein System öffnet, um den nächsten splitternden Balken und sonstigen Webeffekt sehen zu dürfen. Und dabei natürlich sich die unmöglichsten Dinge einhandelt und danach ein Dreivierteljahr böse rumjammern wird, als das übliche Verfahren. Das heißt, man kann Sicherheitsfunktionen reinbauen, so viel man will, solange die nicht absolut angezogen sind, während die Nutzer mit wahnsinniger Begeisterung sich in die unsichersten Gebiete reinbauen. Genau so wie die Leute eben unter 30 durch eine Baustelle fahren mit dem Auto.
Das sagt uns natürlich nichts anderes, als dass wir da nichts dagegen tun können.
Man kann einfach nur darüber berichten, darüber informieren. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt. Wir hatten heute zum Beispiel das wunderschöne Problem, dass es möglich ist, mit Hilfe eines Programmes namens Frontpage Webseiten zu aktualisieren. Das ist eine wunderbare Funktion.
Das ist auch ein Microsoft-Programm, oder? Das ist auch ein Microsoft-Programm?
Ja, natürlich.
Was kannst du damit machen? Du kannst andere Leute Homepages...
Frontpage Webseiten editieren.
Wenn die mit Frontpage erstellt wurden?
Ja, wenn der Web-Server das unterstützt, dann muss da ein paar spezielle Funktionen...
Achso, alles klar, ja.
Bisher konnten wir nur noch Microsoft-Web-Server und seit Anfang der Woche kann es eben auch Apache und die üblichen freien Web-Servers, so dass damit zu rechnen, ist, dass das innerhalb der nächsten vier Wochen eine sehr weite Verbreiterung erreichen wird. Du brauchst nicht mehr hacken die Maschinen, du kannst das einfach so machen.
Wenn die Unix-Server diese Frontpage-Erweiterungen bei sich drauf haben, auf dem Unix-System.
Und wenn die nicht durch einen guten Firewall abgeschützt sind. Das muss man dazu sagen, das ist auch nicht ein Problem von Frontpage. Das ist kein Fehler von Frontpage. Frontpage benutzt ja nur etwas, was auch Netzkafe Navigator Gold benutzt. Das Problem liegt an der Stelle bei den Servern bzw. an den Systeminstallationen.
Die Leute bauen alles auf, die machen jede Tür auf, nur damit sie denken, sie machen was Gutes. Wenn du die Sicherheitsumgebung an irgendeiner Stelle aufmachst, dann werden die Leute es aufmachen, einfach nur um zu sehen. Oha, es funktioniert. Genial.
Sag mal, Lutz, was mich jetzt natürlich auch interessiert, ich weiß nicht genau, was dein sonstiges Betätigungsfeld ist, was du beruflich machst und so weiter. Du machst was?
Brötchenverdienen.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, als was oder mit was. Aber ist insofern auch nicht wichtig für die Frage, weil je mehr man weiß über ein Thema, desto mehr hält man sich ja davon fern oder desto besser kann man bestimmte Sachen natürlich benutzen und einsetzen. Also wenn ich weiß, dass 130 durch die Baustelle nicht besonders clever ist, dann fahre ich eben langsamer. Was ist das langsame Fahren jetzt, das Äquivalent für dich am Computer im Netz? Wie verhältst du dich im Netz? Benutzt du, weiß ich nicht, den Explorer auf keinen Fall? Schaltest du ActiveX ab? Schaltest du Java ab? Wie verhältst du dich im Netz?
Ja, zwei Dinge. Internet Explorer läuft bei mir nicht. Punkt eins, Punkt zwei, aufgrund des Betriebssystems. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Der Netscape läuft bei mir auch kaum noch, weil er nicht in der Lage ist, bei uns auf die Secure Server drauf zu bekommen. Er ist schlicht und ergreiflich nicht in der Lage, mit vernünftigen Schlüsselgrößen zu rechnen. Das ist er unfähig. Sodass ich im Endeffekt mehr oder weniger auf handgeschriebenes Zeug angewiesen bin. Das heißt, man nehme sich eine Quelle, zum Beispiel eine Maya her, und freiverfügbare Software passt die an.
Das heißt, du arbeitest unter was?
In dem Fall unter Linux, ja.
Verstehe. Gut, ja, dann hast du ja seine Probleme nicht. Was ist dein Tipp für Benutzer von normalsterblichen Betriebssystemen, Windows, Mac OS und so weiter?
Augen auf. Augen auf und erst mal nachdenken. Aber das passiert eh nicht.
Also du bist da sozusagen nicht sehr optimistisch.
Nö, überhaupt nicht. Du brauchst dir nur mal angucken, wie die Leute vorm Rechner sitzen.
Na ja, gut, aber trotzdem ist ja die Frage, also wenn sie ActiveX irgendwie zulassen oder wenn sie Softwareprodukte haben, die ActiveX zulassen und so rum, dann ist es ja schon was anderes, als wenn da jetzt Java-Dinger reinkommen, die zunächst einmal...
Natürlich ist das was anderes, nur erwarte mal, wie viele Leute dann auf so eine Box reagieren werden, worauf sie jetzt darf denn dieses Programm jetzt drucken. Dann werden sie sagen, ja, nein. Wenn das Programm sicher gemacht ist, dann werden sie diese Frage regelmäßig bekommen. Dann werden sie sich darüber aufregen und einen wahnsinnigen Consumerdruck machen, wie das so schön heißt, dass das Ding doch immer eingeschaltet sein soll. Und dann gibt es irgendwelche Voreinstellungen, dass man das auch tatsächlich machen kann. Die sind irgendwo versteckt. Na gut, dann wird es eben firmenintern so ausgeliefert, dass das Zeug alles eingeschaltet ist. Erwartet das dann nichts. Das ist genau das Problem an der Stelle. Die Leute begreifen es nicht. Das kann man ihnen nicht unbedingt zum Vorwurf machen. Sie wollen ja was sehen.
Ich wollte auch gerade sagen, das Problem ist ja, das ist sicher auch eine ganz andere Sendung, aber das Problem ist natürlich auch die Art, wie Leute an Computer und Internet und so weiter herangeführt werden. Ich meine, von dem, weiß ich nicht, den Versprechungen, es ist das neue Fernsehen und bla und so, da liegt das Problem natürlich viel tiefer, wie bei allen Problemen, die man so kennt.
Also wenn du den Leuten versuchst, was zu verkaufen, erwarte die auf, dass du Leistung liest.
Ja, natürlich. Und genauso ist das natürlich...
Wenn ich den Leuten Sicherheitstechnik verkaufe, was ich als Hotelmeister tue, dann wissen die Leute, dass sie sich beispielsweise nicht beim Arbeiten den Finger schneiden dürfen, weil sie dann in schlicht und ergreifend ihre Maschinen nicht mehr rankommen.
Lutz, vielen, vielen Dank erstmal. Ich hoffe, wir hören uns mal wieder.
Kurzmeldungen.
Moskau. Die amerikanische Computerfirma Sun hat einen neuen Weg gefunden, das amerikanische Verbot für den Export starker Verschlüsselungsprodukte zu umgehen. Die Moskauer Firma Elvis & Co. vertreibt zukünftig ein auf der Basis von Sun's Skip-Algorithmus entwickeltes Verschlüsselungssystem. Welche Konsequenzen dieses Verfahren der Nachentwicklung amerikanischer Software im Ausland auf die Exportregulierung hat, ist noch unklar. Um die Regierung nicht allzu sehr auf die Palme zu bringen, soll dieser Algorithmus offenbar nur in Produkten für sogenanntes Electronic Commerce verbindet werden. Dabei geht es vor allem um ein sicheres Bezahlen im Internet. Vereinigtes Königreich. Die Wahlen im Empire haben einige erstaunliche Softwarefehler der London Times und der BBC offenbart. Bei der London Times konnten die erstaunten Leser zwei Tage nach der Wahl für einige Wahlkreise nur Nullen und Not-a-Number-Fehlermeldungen statt der erwarteten Prozentzahlen bewundern. Bei der BBC wurde die zweite Null hinter dem Komma schlicht weggeschnitten. Ob es auch Fehler in der staatlichen Auswertesoftware gab und ob die überdurchschnittliche Quote von Labour-Wählern unter den Programmierern etwas mit dem Wahlergebnis zu tun hatte, ist bisher nicht bekannt. Texas, der für seine Gastfreundlichkeit bekannte US-Bundesstaat hat seit einiger Zeit Besucher besonderer Art. Verschiedene Ameisenarten bevölkern Kabelschächte und EDV-Anlagen. Kurzschlüsse und zerfressene Kabelisolierungen sorgen regelmäßig für Ausfälle und langwierige Fehlersuche. Wie schnell der Vormarsch der wärmeliebenden Tierchen nach Norden fortschreitet, wird sich an den Fehlermeldungen der Rechnerbetreiber ablesen lassen. Eine christliche Sekte bezeichnete die Ameisen als Gottesstrafe für die Klimaerwärmung. Deutschland, seit Visa auch in Deutschland Kreditkarten mit dem Verfallsdatum 2000 ausgibt, häufen sich auch hier die Fälle von gescheiterten Transaktionen. Die Zahlungsterminals kommen mit dem als 00-kodierten Verfallsjahr 2000 nicht klar und stürzen ab. Ob und wann es Abhilfe geben wird, ist auch unklar. Amiland, das neue nationale Luftfahrt-Kontrollzentrum der USA, liegt mit seinem Eröffnungstermin massiv hinter dem Zeitplan. In den etwa 1, 8 Millionen Zeilen pro Grammcode befinden sich geschätzte 120.000 Fehler, die zurzeit mit einer Geschwindigkeit von 500 pro Monat entfernt werden. Der Zeitplan ist schon um 15 Monate überzogen und eine schnelle Lösung ist nicht in Sicht. Die Entwicklung ist mit 570 Millionen Dollar veranschlagt. Nach Debugging kann sich diese Zahl leicht noch mal verdoppeln. Planet Erde, etliche unter OpenVMS laufende Großrechner der Firma Digital Equipment haben eine Art vorzeitiges Jahr 2000 Problem. Aufgrund eines Datumsüberlaufes in einer veralteten, aber populären Systemfunktion fand sich am Morgen des 19. Mai zum Beispiel Polizeidienststellen in Kalifornien und anderen Bundesstaaten ohne Daten wieder. DECK hat einen Patch herausgebracht. Experten rechnen aber damit, dass sich Fehler dieser Art in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren häufen werden.
Gut, ihr habt sie gehört, die Internetnews. Ihr habt aber viel über ActiveX und Java gehört. Ihr habt Wurz am Telefon gehört. Ihr habt über die Sicherheitsmücken gehört. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, wenn ihr Korrekturen, wenn ihr Kommentare habt, wenn ihr Zusätze habt, ruft uns an. Ich hoffe, dass inzwischen jeder die Telefonnummer kennt.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 74 81 110.
You're flying with Chaosradio Hunt.
Sven.
Sven, hallo.
Hi, ich hab mal eine Frage. Ich hab vor kurzem mal mir NepNight angesehen im Fernsehen. Die hatten ein kleines Problem gehabt.
Was hast du gesehen?
NepNight auf dem ZDF. Also auf einmal meinten sie, sie haben irgendein Problem und so weiter und da war die Sendung eigentlich schon gestorben.
Die war zu Ende oder was?
Naja, also irgendwie kamen sie nicht mehr raus.
Wie raus?
Naja, die konnten irgendwie nicht mehr surfen, ich weiß auch nicht genau, was da los war. Sie haben auch nichts weiter, kein Wort verloren, haben die gerne die ganze Sendung darüber versucht, Sebastian nochmal eine Vergnügung herzukriegen.
Achso, Internet. Ihr Internet ist weggerieselt. Naja, überrascht natürlich nicht unbedingt.
Ja, das passiert aber auch selber auch mal, oder?
Na, das war zumindest live, das muss man hinlassen. Also man sollte sich da eigentlich besser absichern, hast du recht. Oder hast du jetzt noch eine konkrete Frage dazu?
Nee, also einfach so eine Live-Sendung, dass da einfach mal die Leitung zusammenbricht, kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen.
Naja, das zeigt, dass die Dienstgüte im Servicebereich Internet noch lange nicht so hoch ist wie im Servicebereich Telefon.
Wobei das natürlich eine prinzipielle Frage ist, gibt es überhaupt den Servicebereich Internet? Also ich warte ja wirklich nachdem wir die Medien das Internet verkaufen, an den, sagen wir mal, durchschnittlichen Computer-User, warte ich auf den ersten User, der versucht das Internet zu verklagen, weil die Inhalte nicht die sind, die er sucht oder so was. Also gibt es den Servicebereich Internet? Es gibt sicher den Servicebereich Internet Provider, aber doch nicht für das Internet selber.
Naja, dieser Streitfall der Verantwortlichkeit und der Zuständigkeit, das durchzieht ja auch diese ganzen Diskussionen. Wer ist denn nun eigentlich für die eigentliche Veröffentlichung jetzt derjenige, den man dingfest machen kann, falls irgendwas nicht in Ordnung ist? Da hatten wir vor zwei Monaten diese Sache mit Österreich, die komplett abgeschaltet haben, weil halt ein Serviceprovider von der Polizei mehr oder minder komplett beschlagnahmt wurde aus Protest. Und beim Routing, also bei den tatsächlichen technischen Betriebsproblemen, ist es ähnlich. Wenn ich eine Verbindung zu irgendeinem anderen System nicht herstellen kann, dann kann es an meinem Equipment liegen, dann kann es an meinem Internetprovider liegen, aber in der Regel liegt es an irgendeinem anderen Internet-Serviceprovider, der dazwischen liegt. Das Problem ist an sich lösbar, weil das haben wir ja im Telefonnetz auch. Nur auf Internet, auf diesen Sprung sind sie einfach so schnell, auf diesen Zug sind sie so schnell aufgestiegen zu einem Zeitpunkt, als ganz klar absehbar war, dass es einfach noch eine Weile dauert, bis dieselbe Dienstgüte erreicht werden kann. Das wird überhaupt erst möglich sein, wenn der neue IP-Standard sich durchsetzt.
Die technischen Probleme sind noch lange nicht gelöst.
Sven, danke dir erstmal.
Ja, ich hätte da noch... Und zwar, ich hatte da was gelesen vor kurzem, und zwar über irgendwas, was Windnuke heißt.
Wie bitte?
Ein kleines C-Programm für Linus-Kisten, Fankisten und bla.
Ist, glaube ich, kein Active Windnuke-Control.
Ich glaube, das hing mit dieser Out-of-Band-Attacke zusammen.
Stimmt das oder Ping-of-Death?
Ja, eins von beiden, ich bin mir grad nicht sicher. Es gab da zwei Sachen, die relativ weit verbreitet waren. Das eine war Ping-of-Death, wo man ein Ping-Paket geschickt hat, das zu groß war. Was die Systeme nicht erwartet haben, dass es zu groß ist, und damit Sachen überschrieben wurden, die für das System wichtig waren, was zum Absturz führten. Das andere, was das sein könnte, war ein Problem, das unter Windows und Windows NT aufgetreten ist. Und zwar definiert das TCP-Protokoll sogenannte Out-of-Band-Data, also Daten, die man zusätzlich zur Verbindung noch rüberschickt, um extra Informationen zu übertragen, die mit dem Inhalt nichts zu tun haben. Und wenn man jetzt ein Out-of-Band-Data-Paket geschickt hat, das leer war, an ein Windows-Rechner, dann ist dieser Windows-Rechner abgestürzt.
Ja, ich glaube, das war auch Vinuc. Bei ActiveX gibt es was Ähnliches, das heißt Internet-Exploder. Das war noch etwas populärer als unser Hack, auch weil es ein Amerikaner geschrieben hat. Sun hat das auf seiner Java-Konferenz auch stolz allen Anwesenden präsentiert. Hier zeige ich Ihnen ein Programm, das heißt Internet-Exploder. Es tut halt das, was der Name verspricht. Dann budet sich der Rechner neu. Es tut also genau das Gleiche auf eine andere Art und Weise.
Es macht Windows kaputt.
Im Chat wundert man sich unter anderem darüber, dass ihr NetNight nicht kennt. Ich kenne das aber auch nicht. Ich gucke aber auch kein Fernsehen.
Ich habe auch nicht die Zeit dafür.
Ich wusste noch gar nicht, dass das ZDF schon betroffen hat, dass es Internet gibt.
Also ich klicke lieber selber.
Ganz klar, mit der Fernbedienung auch.
Wobei ZDF macht jetzt auch dick mit Microsoft zusammen. Die Microsoft-Network ihren Service-Gram und so höchst verwerflich ist.
Deswegen ist sie gestern mal abgestürzt.
Was schreiben sie denn noch hier?
Die hat Microsoft-Network als Provider beim ZDF und der Garantie. Jetzt wissen wir auch, warum es abgestürzt ist.
Oh man, da kommen dann aber auch Zitate hier. Bill Gates ist der Hitler der 90er Jahre. Da würde ich aber vorher mal den Kopf einschalten, ich glaube nicht, dass Hitler so viel Software verkauft hat.
Sonny, haben wir keine Hörer?
Ach so, ihr wollt mit Hörern reden, ich hab hier gerade ein bisschen gelesen. Ja mach ich ja. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hier Steffen.
Steffen, hallo.
So Jungs, erzählt mal, ihr sagt die ganze Zeit, dass man für Java müsste was geschrieben werden. Also es müsste mit Java programmiert werden.
Nein, man kann ja mit programmieren.
Naja, ich finde es doch ganz schön, wenn es ein bisschen mehr gäbe. Sag doch uns mal, womit man unter Linux und Java programmiert.
Es gibt ein Port, das ist JDK für Linux meines Wissens.
Gibt es, auch schon das 1.1. Und das musst du dir runterlagen, kannst du sicherlich bei java.sun.com oder www.javasoft.com oder irgendwo sonst?
Nee, nee, ich meine ja doch eine Entwicklungsumgebung.
Ja, ja, das ist eine. Das ist das Java Development Kit und zwar das, was sowieso auch auf allen anderen Plattformen zum Laufen gebracht wird, bloß eben in unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen, teilweise mit Umgebungen von Andrit-Herstellern, kompletten Entwicklungsumgebungen wie zum Beispiel Visual Cafe von Symantec oder auch dieses Java-Workshop von Sun selber. Da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Sachen. Auch Microsoft hat sein eigenes, da heißt es J++, damit sie für den Namen Java nicht auch noch Geld an Sun bezahlen müssen. Und unter Linux ist es mindestens dieses JDK, das ist sozusagen das nackte Java-Entwicklungskit, ohne viel Gimmick drumrum. Aber das erlaubt dir alles zu programmieren, wie bei den anderen auch. Bloß nicht so komfortabel, zum Testen reicht das auf jeden Fall aus. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber es gibt auch schon in Java geschriebene Java-Entwicklungspakete, ich weiß nicht genau, wie weit die sind, aber auf jeden Fall in Arbeit, die dann natürlich auch unter Linux laufen, wenn alles richtig ist. Und ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn auch noch weitere, umfangreichere Entwicklungspakete, auch wenn die noch verfügbar werden. Bei den anderen Plattformen ist das schon der Fall.
Ja, also was ich meinte, war schon nicht das JDK, sondern eine IDE halt.
Ja, also da habe ich jetzt gerade keinen konkreten Tipp, aber vielleicht weiß den ja jemand.
Gibt es das für C++ auch nicht? Also natürlich gibt es eine IDE in zwei Emacs, aber da ist man halt bereit, sich dann darauf einzulassen.
Du meinst vor allem natürlich eine, wo man besser mit Applets arbeiten kann, die ja im Wesentlichen grafisch orientiert ist. Wird Kram, ich weiß es jetzt nicht.
Und wenn es im Ernstland nur eine Online-Hilfe ist oder sowas?
Na gut, die Online-Hilfe, der ganze Java-Kram ist ja sowieso in HTML ausgeliefert. Also die Dokumentation ist ja auch in HTML und das kriegst du ja auch so Probleme zum Laufen. Das ist auch alles online, kannst du dir auch als Paket runterladen und hast es dann lokal, ohne dass du Internet haben musst.
Dann noch mal mein Mikro wieder an, danke. Danke, Steffen. Das war kurzfristig weg im Pen. Übrigens, dürft ihr nicht so sauer sein, wenn dieser Chat hier nicht live mit uns wirklich funktioniert. Ich zippe ab und zu, hier weiß einer, aber es ist natürlich völlig utopisch, dass wir hier live mit euch chatten, dann Radio machen und auch noch unsere E-Mail lesen und die Monster am besten auch gleich noch live abspielen. Das geht nicht, Kinder, das geht nicht. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaos Radio. Ey, du bist extrem leise. Warte, ich probier nochmal. Ja, sehr viel besser. Wunderbar. Sehr schön.
Ich hab mal ne Frage an euch. Und zwar, wo denkt ihr, geht das alles hin? Also zu einen blanken wir von der Software, dass das System immer mehr verzagt wird, auch mit dem Internet. Und andererseits sagt ihr, naja, es hat gewisse Sicherheitsrisiken.
Das ist eine generelle Frage, die ich ja gerne sowieso mal in einer anderen Sendung dann auch so ein bisschen mehr philosophieren kann. Wo geht das alles überhaupt hin? Das ist natürlich die Frage, weswegen wir so ein bisschen hier sind mit dieser Sendung, die ich glaube eher philosophisch gemeint, oder?
Nein, ich meine es schon jetzt richtig konkret.
Ach so, schade.
Ja, also ich denke...
Ich meine, wenn man zum Beispiel mitkriegt, dass halt eben sämtliche Textverarbeitungsprogramme der neueren Version halt eben Internet anbieten, die Anbindung daran.
Also, dass das Internet Erfolg haben wird und auch noch in 30 Jahren diesen Planeten, wenn es ihn dann noch gibt, bevölkern wird, das denke ich steht völlig außer Frage. Also Internet ist eigentlich das, worauf alle immer gewartet haben. Man wusste bloß halt vorher nicht, dass es eben das Internet ist. Es hätten ja auch andere Netztechnologien Erfolg haben können, war aber nun mal nicht so. Und zunächst einmal ist dieses Internet überhaupt erst mal das Vorhandensein eines Straßennetzes, sodass man jetzt anfangen kann, die passenden Autos und LKWs dafür zu bauen. Das wird eben derzeit getan. Java deckt einen wesentlichen Bedarf eines solchen Software-Modells, in dem es vor allem Plattformunabhängigkeit mit reinbringt, was einfach gefordert ist, weil am Internet alle teilnehmen. Der Gedanke, dass man sich auf eine Plattform in den nächsten 10-20 Jahren einigt, das wird nicht stattfinden. Egal wie erfolgreich Windows sein wird, sie werden niemals an 99% herankommen. Wahrscheinlich haben sie auch schon ihr Maximum erreicht. Eine noch größere Sättigung kann man sich fast gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Vielleicht sind da noch ein paar Prozentzahlen drin, aber irgendwo ist Schluss. Java zeigt auf, wie sich auch der Rest der Softwareindustrie wehrt, weil sie eben gar keine Lust haben, sich auf die Microsoft-Sachen zu stützen. Weil es eben so, wie sich Microsoft verhält, sind sie nicht nur sehr unpopulär, sondern sie rauben auch wirklich allen anderen Firmen mittlerweile in ihren Heimatbereichen, rauben sie eben irgendwelche Einnahmen. Es gibt also kaum noch einen Softwarebereich, der wirklich unangetastet wäre von Microsoft. Sie sind nicht unbedingt in allen erfolgreich, aber eben in den wichtigsten sind sie eben extrem erfolgreich und das erdrückt schon eine ganze Menge.
Ja, ich meine, da habt ihr ja natürlich auch ein Problem, weil zum Beispiel das Betriebssystem, wo nun Java wirklich integriert ist, also nicht nur am Browser, sondern eben richtig integriert ist, nämlich OS2, das habt ihr ja nun manchmal mit einem Wort erwähnt.
Ja, das mit OS2 erwähnen ist immer so ein Problem. Ich kann das gerne erwähnen. Ich weiß auch, dass OS2 das erste Betriebssystem war, was wirklich jetzt per offizieller Shipping-Auslieferung vom Hersteller eben, von IBM, Java komplett im Betriebssystem mit drin hat. Das leisten mittlerweile natürlich auch andere Betriebssysteme, bei Unix war die Integration sowieso schon immer relativ einfach. Also da muss man nicht so sehr viel machen, um das zu integrieren. Und bei anderen Plattformen, wie zum Beispiel Mac OS, ist es mittlerweile auch verfügbar, nicht unbedingt immer in den neuesten Versionen. Bei Windows ist es nur deshalb nicht im Betriebssystem und genau darüber reden wir ja gerade, weil Microsoft das eben gar nicht haben will. Also zumindest, also sie können sich nicht wirklich gegen Java wehren. Aber zunächst einmal unterläuft Java ganz massiv. Sie haben nämlich ihre Pläne, nämlich ActiveX durchzusetzen. Nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil einfach ActiveX die Sicherung ihrer Märkte für die nächsten 10, 20 Jahre bedeutet.
Ich glaube, was noch ein relativ großer Hemmschuh ist, also vielleicht Java zu entwickeln, ist natürlich auch die Tatsache, dass es im Moment also ziemlich viele Änderungen gibt. Also ich meine, wenn man so den Unterschied zwischen 1.2. und 1.0.2. und 1.1. sieht, jetzt demnächst 1.2. die jeweiligen Versionen, da hat man ja auch keine Sicherung als Firma, wenn man irgendwas programmiert ist, dass es halt eben mit der nächsten Java-Version laufen wird. Ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Problem, ne?
Ja, aber man muss sagen, also jetzt diese 1.1. Geschichte ist ja nicht Java die Programmiersprache 1.1. An der Sprache hat sich nichts geändert. Und da wird sich auch auf absehbare Zeit nichts im Wesentlichen verändern, sondern woran Sun jetzt derzeit bastelt, dass es eben die Weiterentwicklung dieser API, also der Plattform. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon aufgezeigt, dass eben zu diesem Buzzword Java mindestens vier Teile gehören, nämlich die Programmiersprache und eben auch die Plattform, die ja eigentlich das ist, was Windows konkret Konkurrenz macht, weil es eine ähnliche Mächtigkeit hat. Plus diese Mächtigkeit kann natürlich auch Sun sich nicht von heute auf morgen aus dem Ärmel schütteln. Allein schon deshalb, weil ja Sun auch nicht die Einzigen sind, die da was mitzureden haben, weil Sun weiß, die können nicht gegen alle anderen, die nicht Microsoft sind, angehen und auch noch Erfolg haben, sondern alle verbünden sich. Da sitzt Apple mit im Boot, natürlich Netscape vor allem, aber auch IBM hat sehr viel Geld und Energie und Marketing in diesen Java-Weg reingebaut, vor allem mit ihrem Kampfschiff Lotus Notes, was auch sehr viel Gebrauch machen wird von Java-Technologie. Und so haben sie dann überhaupt die Möglichkeit über diese erweiterte API, die halt auch die Intelligenz von viel Erfahrung aus den letzten 20 Jahren jetzt so schrittweise mit in diese Java-Sache reinbringt. Das geht ja nicht von heute auf morgen. Wir werden also auch noch ein Java 1.3 sehen und es wird auch auf jeden Fall 1.2.0 geben, aber der wesentliche Zugewinn wird eben leichte Änderungen und vor allem wesentliche Neuerrungenschaften bedeuten.
Eine Frage, die ich noch hätte, ist, Java als solches direkt von Sun spezifizieren die das alleine oder kann es passieren, dass es so wie in anderen Programmiersprachen, Programmierdialekten halt eben passiert wie C++, dass zehn verschiedene Firmen der Süppchen kochen, also das ganze Ding im Grundkontext zwar einig ist, aber dass man das eine C++ Programm nicht mit dem anderen Compiler verwenden kann.
Ja, also Sun hat die Java-Plattform, also auch die Sprache, also erstmal die Sprache vor allem, später sicherlich auch die Plattform, vorgeschlagen als ISO EEC-Standard. Es gibt da bereits eine Working Group, die sich aktiv damit befasst. Es gab ein White Paper von Sun, wo sie ausführlich dargelegt haben, wie sie sich eben diesen Weg in diese Standardisierungswelt vorgestellt haben. Daraufhin gab es einige Einwände, natürlich von Microsoft, aber eben auch von Apple, also auch von den anderen Partnerfirmen, die alle ihre Belange auch noch berücksichtigt sehen wollen. Darüber wird sicherlich noch ein bisschen diskutiert werden, aber dieser Weg wird angestoßen, also dessen ist sich Sun bewusst. Sie können einfach nur über den Maximalweg, sie können einfach nur sagen, Java ist jetzt wirklich ein verbriefter Standard, den werden auch Regierungen akzeptieren, weil da steht ISO davor. Und auf dem Weg haben sie natürlich eine sehr viel größere Chance, weil Microsoft-Technologie sich auf der Ebene von ISO-Standards durchsetzen wird, das steht glaube ich völlig außer Frage.
Ist es denn nun eigentlich im Java möglich direkt auf das Daten zu zugreifen, also zum Beispiel in einer Java-Applikation, bekanntestes sicherlich ist Core Office zu Java. Also ich habe bloß die erste Betterness, da konnte man zum Beispiel noch nicht speichern. Ist das irgendwie integriert oder was?
Theoretisch gab es von Anfang an im Java das Modell der Sandbox, das heißt, dass man nicht auf lokale Daten zugreifen kann, sondern bloß auf den Bildschirm und auf die Tastatur. Und das steht natürlich Applikation, die auf dem Rechner selber laufen im Wege. Also diese Sandbox ist eigentlich für Applets gedacht, für Programme, die auf Webseiten sind und die automatisch ausgeführt werden. Wenn ich mir allerdings ein Office-Paket im Laden kaufe, das in Java programmiert ist, besteht kein Grund dafür, dass ich die Sicherheitsmechanismen einschalten muss. Und deshalb gibt es jetzt eine Aufweichung dieser Sandbox, in der Programme dann auch speichern können und drucken können und so weiter.
Ich kann dir noch einen Hinweis geben. Die Idee bei Java ist ja auch die Förderung dieses Konzeptes des Netzwerkcomputers. Das ist ja ein Gerät, das überhaupt keine lokale Daten vorhalten soll. Man soll das zentral machen. Von daher gibt es da überhaupt keine Grenze, die dann auch überschritten werden muss. Die Sandbox ist sozusagen der Computer selber. Der hat noch nicht mal ein Diskettenlaufwerk, der hat nur einen Bildschirm, eine Tastatur, einen Prozessor, eine Menge Speicher und im besten Fall hat er noch eine PC-Karte, so ein Slot für die Authentifizierung und Verschlüsselung. Auf jeden Fall ist es gar nicht nötig bei dem Modell, dass man sozusagen lokal auf Dateien zugreift, weil die greifen auf dem Server zu und da sollen sie ja auch zugreifen. Das macht alles nur einfacher. Wir hatten das vorhin ja angerissen. Das ähnelt so ein bisschen wie das bei Unix schon immer lief. Der große Rechner, an dem mehrere Leute gleichzeitig arbeiten. Plus dieses Multi-User-Konzept ist halt immer nur begrenzt, so schnell wie der Rechner arbeiten kann. Wenn man diese Network-Computer hat, dann nehmen die ganze Rechenlast für den lokalen Kram ab. Aber die Speicherung, die erfolgt nach wie vor zentral. Das macht eigentlich sehr viel Sachen einfacher zu verwalten. Für Systemadministratoren ist das eine sehr verlockende Sache. Da kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es eine Menge Erfolg damit haben wird. Vielleicht wäre der Weg ja gar nicht schlecht. Unix wird ja auch noch benutzt. Und Internet ist auch zurück zu den 60ern. Das ist das, was da mal ausgedacht wurde, wie das eigentlich alles sein sollte. Danach kamen halt nur Gimmicks. Weder Netbios noch Apple Talk haben irgendwie die Kraft gehabt, das zu leisten, was das Internet kann. Und wahrscheinlich ist auch dieses Host- und Client-Modell, was Java hat und was Unix und Terminals vorher hatten, vielleicht gar nicht mal das Falsche. Weil PCs, vollwertiger PC für 5000 Mark, für jeden, der irgendwie mal einen Text schreiben muss, vollkommener Quatsch. Da reicht auch ein Computer für Draunertmark.
Steffen, ich sag dir erst mal Tschüss, ja? Ja, kannst du gleich machen, wir sind noch mal kurz aus Klohe. Chaosradio im Blue Moon bei Fritz, noch bis 1 Uhr. Wir reden über Java, ActiveX, Sicherheitslücken, Zukunft und so weiter und so fort. Ihr könnt uns E-Mails schreiben unter chaos.orb.de. Ihr könnt natürlich auch ganz normale Postkarten schreiben an Chaosradio Fritz, Postfach 90 9000 in 14 439 Potsdam. Ihr könnt hier nach dem Fritz-Info weiter anrufen unter 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110. Ihr könnt unter www.fritz.de slash speakers slash chat in unserer Beta-Version, die von Nutz Schramm vorhin fertiggestellt worden ist, chatten mit ein paar netten Leuten, die hier über Pizzadienste reden. Macht das nicht, krieg Hunger. Ihr könnt natürlich auch die Chaos-Homepages besuchen unter www.ccc.de und unter slash Chaosradio gibt es dann auch noch mehr zu dieser Sendung.
Ich werde es ändern.
Auch das, wenn wir noch hinkriegen. Was gibt es sonst noch zu sagen? Ganz besonders interessiert uns natürlich eure Meinung zu ihrer Sendung und vor allen Dingen würde ich gerne, also mich speziell interessiert, ob es nicht auch möglich wäre, ein bisschen philosophischer zu werden auch mal in diesen Sendungen.
Deswegen haben wir doch Andi dabei.
Ich möchte nicht nur die CT der Radiowelt sein.
Das ist dann ja die Sinnvolle nach dem wohin, was wir da vorhin hatten. Wo wird das alles noch hin für ein Flapp-Magazin?
Ich möchte hier nicht nur die CT sein, sondern eine bessere und europäischere Version von Wired vielleicht. Also Wired ist ja inzwischen ein sehr enttäuschendes Magazin, wie ich finde, weil die bestimmte Entwicklung im Netz überhaupt nicht mehr mitkriegen und immer nur noch feiern wie so bei Amis üblich. Alles ist toll, super. Dass da längst nicht mehr alles toll ist und auch manchmal keinen Spaß mehr macht, wird aus der Acht gelassen. Das alles werden wir hier im Chaos Radio machen, in den nächsten Monaten, hier im letzten Mittwoch im Monat, mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Es macht schon Spaß, wenn man hier gleichzeitig im Chat so Reaktionen auf das lesen kann, was hier so passiert. Das ist schon ein Klasse, finde ich. Also wir werden auch in Zukunft noch mehr Anbindungen machen, vielleicht irgendwie mal die gesamte Sendung CUC-meme-mäßig ins Netz geben per Video, aber das ist natürlich völlig uninteressant bei uns. Aber solche Sachen werden hier weiter passieren im Chaos Radio. Noch eine halbe Stunde Chaosradio, das sind wieder von euch eingesandte Mods. Per E-Mail hier eingetroffen, irgendwelche Musik von euch. Ich kann deinen Mod nicht spielen. Das kommt per E-Mail hier an, aber ich kann es einfach nicht sofort abspielen. Das geht nicht. Es muss erstens auch in einen anderen Rechner übertragen werden. Da ist super, dass mir jemand Bescheid sagt, wann diese Mods aufhören.
Das ist jetzt vorbei, der Song. Danke.
Hey, aber es ist hier im Chaosradio. Das war wieder ein von euch eingesandtes Mod, ein Sound-File. Und nochmal der Aufruf, wenn ihr irgendwas bastelt zu Hause, wenn es nur für euch ist, dann schickt es uns trotzdem zu. Wir gucken, ob wir es interessant genug finden. Wenn es Sounds sind, dann nehmen wir sie hier spielen. Aber eine große Bitte, wenn ihr größere Files schickt, schickt uns erst eine kurze Mail, ob das okay ist oder so. Also schickt nicht bitte unaufgefordert, irgendwie Megabyte große Files, das nervt tierisch zumal.
Wir nehmen auch Disketten.
Wir nehmen auch Disketten, genau, da ist es wirklich besser, eine Diskette rüberzuschicken.
Oder schickt eine URL, das ist einfach.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich finde, Diskette, das Problem ist, es gibt einfach Lesefehler, die einen, die Disketten bekommen haben.
Disketten sind veraltet.
Aber die gibt es ziemlich überall. Ich würde sagen, schickt uns keine andere Möglichkeit, dann schickt uns Disketten.
Ich habe hier meine Mail bei Fritz und die wird noch mal geroutet zu meinem Heim-Internet-Anschluss sozusagen und dann lese ich hier irgendwie, wenn drei Mods mit einem Megabyte kommen, sitze ich jedes Mal stundenlang da und gucke dazu, wie die...
Dann müssen wir dich halt einfach aus der Mail-Liste rausnehmen.
Wenn du nicht bandbreitenkompatibel bist.
War super. Wo soll denn das alles noch hin?
Du sitzt ja hier sowieso schon auf wie so eine arrogante Elite, alle mit Internetzugang, mit teuren Computern zu Hause, mit Telefonanschluss und so und dann muss ich mir auch noch so was vorwerfen lassen.
Das ist ja auch unsere einzige Freude im Leben.
Oh Tim, was hast du vorher abends gemacht?
Ich hab immer zu Hause gegessen.
Du meinst, vorher warst du zu jung zum Sexer? Ja, ihr merkt schon, es chillt etwas aus.
Um ein Mal gibt es hier den Nightfall mit Martin Petersdorf, den der Geruch hier im Studio sich an den Stirn holt.
Wo können wir jetzt in unsere philosophische Phase übergehen?
Ja genau, wir nehmen auch gerne höhere Anrufe zur Frage, wo soll denn das alles noch hinführen?
Die ist aber schon gestellt worden.
Aber nicht mehr jetzt.
Ich meinte jetzt einfach nur so, um sozusagen die Themen zukünftiger Sendung schon mal anzureichern mit Stichwort.
Aber können wir mal ein bisschen erzählen, was in den nächsten Monaten passieren wird?
Ja hoffentlich wird die Sonne schallen.
Ja, naja, nachts ist das nicht so schlimm.
Ähm, wer das verfolgt hat, auf unserer Website, unsere Themenankündigung ist jetzt immer recht vollständig für die nächsten zwei, drei Monate. Allerdings wechselt sie immer recht kurzfristig. Für den nächsten Monat haben wir jetzt reinrutschen lassen, das Thema Copyright und Wares. Da geht es halt um die große Raubkopiererszene, die auf dem Internet und auch schon vor dem Internet da war. Und die sehr aktiv dabei ist, geschützte Software massenhaft zu verteilen. Wir werden bedeuten, wie das im Usenet aussieht. Nicht nur Software, sondern jetzt vor allem neues Stichwort MPEG Layer 3, kodierte Audiodateien, womit es problemlos möglich ist, komplette CDs in brauchbaren Größen aufs Netz zu geben. Und auch dort ist heftig was am Rauschen. Für die Judy-Sendung haben wir Information Warfare auf dem Programm, wie macht man Krieg 2000, wie kann man mit Computern Krieg führen, warum ist das der USA mittlerweile wichtiger, als Atombomben zu schmeißen. EMP-Systeme und solche Themen werden da sicherlich mit anklingen. Danach haben wir uns noch nicht festgelegt, aber wir haben noch so ein paar Themen bei uns auf dem Zettel. Satellitentechnik ist bei uns im Hinterkopf. Wir würden auch bei Interesse, was uns immer interessiert ist, was ihr meint, was wir mal tun sollten, vielleicht dem Usenet, also der Geschichte des Internets vor dem eigentlichen IP widmen, also aus welcher Kultur heraus sich das alles entwickelt hat, welche Personen denn nun tatsächlich maßgeblich beteiligt daran waren, dass diese Software entstanden ist, die GNU-Ecke, also diese ganzen Celebrities vielleicht auch mal näher beleuchten. Da gibt es sehr interessante Leute, nicht nur Linus Torwald, der uns Linux gegeben hat. Wir sind auch immer wieder beeinflusst von aktuellen Tagesgeschehen. Jetzt haben wir diese ActiveX-Sache noch mal reingenommen, um diesen Hack noch mal zu beleuchten. Es gibt in der nahen Zukunft auch noch ein anderes sehr interessantes Ding, was ich gerne ankündigen möchte. Im August wird es in Holland eine Veranstaltung geben, die heißt Hacking in Progress, kurz HIP 97. Das ist die mittlerweile dritte Party von den holländischen Hackern rund um die Hectic-Szene. Heute besser bekannt als der Access for All Internet Service Provider, der sich ja auch immer wieder mit allen anlegt, mit der Bundesanwaltschaft und mit Scientology. Die richten also eine große Party aus, vielmehr ein Campingplatz-Event über drei Tage, vom 8. bis zum 11. August. Das wird dann wie vor vier Jahren schon beim Hacking at the end of the universe so aussehen, dass überall Wagen und Zelte herumstehen und ein langes Ethernet-Kabel von Zelt zu Zelt geht. Jedes Zelt hat garantierte Stromversorgung und Internetanschluss. Und diesmal sicherlich mehr als nur die beiden Modems, die nur vor vier Jahren hatten. Also das ist wirklich das große Ereignis, zumal parallel dazu in den USA, in New York, also wirklich gleichzeitig die HOPE stattfindet. Ich weiß gar nicht wofür das die Abkürzung ist. Ist das die Abkürzung für irgendwas? Ah genau, Hackers of Planet Earth. Und die findet wie gesagt zeitgleich statt. Es wird natürlich eine Internet-Querverschaltung dieser beiden Events geben, sprich alle Hacker auf diesem Planeten, im amerikanischen Kontinent zumindest, im europäischen Kontinent werden also gemeinsam fahren. Ihr seid alle eingeladen da auch hinzukommen.
Und Informationen findet ihr auch jetzt schon im Web unter www.hip97.nl, also in der dritten Punkt zwischen HIP und 97 oder zu der Veranstaltung in New York, zu Hope auf www.2600, also 2600.com.
Genau, das gibt es inzwischen hier im Chat. Ich habe Sachs jetzt auch noch mal über Radio, weil ich es gerade eingetippt habe. Ich tippe da jetzt nichts mehr ein, weil da hat sich jetzt unter anderem noch jemand anders als Chaosradio bei Fritz eingeloggt. Und ich höre nicht, dass es da Verwirrungen gibt.
Da haben wir ein Authentisierungsproblem.
Da haben wir ein Authentisierungsproblem, definitiv. Da muss ich kurz mal darauf aufmerksam machen. Die Vergabe von Namen muss irgendwie so funktionieren, dass es den nur einmal gibt. Aber dafür ist es ja Beta-Software und man probiert das aus. Was wollte ich dazu noch sagen? Ach so, es gibt ein paar interessante Themenvorschläge hier. Vielleicht müsste man so ein... Ein Themenvorschlag ist natürlich die politische Seite, also Demokratisierung durchs Internet oder ist Internet Anarchie? Was stand denn hier gerade noch? Ich weiß nicht, wie ernst der gemeint ist, aber durchaus interessant. Wie stört sich das System bzw. die Regierung mit meinem Computer? Die Frage, wie stört sich das System meines Computers, ist natürlich ziemlich einfach zu beantworten. Da reden wir doch hier von seit zwei Jahren. Was gibt es denn hier noch? Ach, finde ich jetzt nicht. Ich müsste jetzt runterscrollen.
Also wir sind nicht an Ideen arm, soll das nicht heißen. Wir haben immer eine Menge Ideen, können uns bloß immer schwer darauf einigen, was denn wirklich das ist, was man machen soll.
Ja, es geht da nicht darum, dass uns die Ideen fehlen. Da haben wir wirklich eine Menge. Und das sagen wir jetzt nicht nur so, sondern es geht darum, das auch ein bisschen von euch reflektiert zu wissen und auf euch einzugehen. Insofern, wie ich so gerne sage, gerade das älteste interaktive Medium, das es überhaupt gibt, ist ja auch dafür da, dass eure Reaktionen beachtet werden für diese Sendung. Nur bei der Musik lassen wir uns nicht reinquatschen. Soll ich jetzt mal so? Ja, Mutz könnte er schicken, aber nicht, wenn es hier so 80er-Cyntigramm ist.
Das ist doch kein Verbrechen.
Nein, das ist kein Verbrechen. Du hast so schöne Musik.
Gibt es gar keine Anrufe mehr?
Ne, ich hab ja auch nicht aufgerufen. Das ist doch keine große Frage.
Du könntest ja nochmal deine Datenschleuderrede halten, Andi.
Wir geben natürlich auch eine Zeitschrift raus nach wie vor. Die Datenschleuder. Und da könnt ihr zum Beispiel ein Probeexemplar, irgendwie für 5 Mark, oder ein Probeabo, das ist 3, ausgarnen für 10 Mark in Briefmarken, beim CCC in der Schwenke Straße 85 in 20255 Hamburg anfordern. Oder ihr könnt euch auch auf www.ccc.de oder in der neuerdings mehrfrequenzierten Newsgruppen an aktuellen Auseinandersetzungen beteiligen. Sehr interaktiv alles. Johnny, was du eben sagtest, Radio, das interaktivste Medium überhaupt, ist doch Quatsch oder nicht? Ich meine, meintest du da eben das Radio?
Nein, das älteste.
Ja, aber nicht interaktiv. Radio ist immer noch one too many. Das ist immer noch die Welt der Albenmedien.
Interaktiv hat nichts mit many to many zu tun.
Na ja, es hat aber mit der Möglichkeit, ja eben.
Das kann ich im Radio, also wenn ich hier anrufen kann und praktisch damit das Thema selber mitgestalte, dann halte ich das für extrem interaktiv.
Jetzt müssen wir den Leuten nur noch beibringen, dass sie es vielleicht auch tun.
Ja, das tun sie, das tun sie eigentlich hier in rauen Massen. Ich erinnere an die letzte Sendung, da waren die Leitungen die ganze Zeit voll. Hier ist es einfach jetzt ein technischeres und schwieriges Thema gewesen. Und das ist auch okay, ich glaube, da hören die Leute einfach ein bisschen mehr zu.
Letztes Mal war es aber auch wirklich der Lokalvorteil. Ich denke, dass das Thema der Sendung sehr in diesen lokal-patriotischen Kreis reingefallen ist. Das ist aber auch wirklich sehr interessant.
Alles, was Nostalgie angeht, ist natürlich immer ein gefundenes Fressen für alle. Also wenn man sich darüber unterhält, wie es früher war, das ist doch bei allen Leuten so.
Damals war noch alles besser.
Vielleicht könnten sich die Herren im Webchat noch mal zu dem möglichen Thema Internetgeschichte äußern. Internetgeschichte?
Ja, im Chat. Ich darf ja nicht mehr posten, aber hier schreibt jemand, das echteste interaktive Medium wäre Postitution. Erstens ist es kein Medium, zweitens ist die männliche Vorstellung, dass es interaktiv wäre, doch ein bisschen weit hergeholt. Ich glaube, da haben die Damen...
Du meinst, das ist auch one too many?
Das ist eher one too many.
Der Webchat ist übrigens in Java vorgelegt, richtig?
Wie kommen wir an Jonnies Konto ran? Das ist ganz einfach. Ich gebe die Konto-Nummer durch und ihr überweist. Das ist dann many to one sozusagen.
Auf dem zweiten Trio-Album stand der Satz, dass sie auf ihrem ersten Album ihre Telefonnummer veröffentlicht hätten und daraufhin viele Anrufe bekommen hätten. Das hätte sie ermutigt, auf dem zweiten Album ihre Konto überanzulassen. Die ganze Wahrheit.
Apropos Wahrheit, vielleicht können wir nochmal auf die Seifenbox steigen und die Technologien nennen, die eigentlich die Zukunft bestimmen werden. Java ist selbstverständlich nur ein Übergang, damit der Schock nicht so groß ist für die ganzen Leute. Also die eigentliche Programmiersprache der Zukunft ist natürlich die Sprache Dillon. Und eigentlich von Apple entwickelt, mittlerweile von Apple eingestellt, aber es wird demnächst von der Firma Harlequin ein Produkt geben, ein Dillon-Compiler für Windows NT. Und es gibt auch von der CMU demnächst einen freiheitlichen Compiler für Dillon. Und Dillon ist die Sprache, in der einfach alles richtig gemacht wurde.
URLs zu diesen und anderen Themen findet ihr nach der Sendung immer in den Postings, die ich über den Chaosradio-Ticker rausschicke. Ihr könnt euch registrieren im Chaosradio-Ticker über unsere Chaosradio-Homepage unter www.ccc.de und weiterklicken. Dort steht, welche Mail ihr wohin schicken müsst, um euch dort einschreiben zu lassen. Es sind schon 340 Leute in diesem Ticker. Das macht uns etwas stolz. Wir versuchen auch weiterhin die Inhalte der Sendung darüber abzudecken und anzupacken.
Es gibt übrigens eine Reaktion von Zen im Chat, der sagt, Usenet würde ihn interessieren. Das Thema immerhin, einer.
Ich denke, dass die meisten Leute im Internet auch immer noch, also mehr als die Hälfte, sind immer noch die Neulinge, so lange so viele dazukommen.
Hier gibt es einen ganz interessanten Themavorschlag, der vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob er richtig ernst gemeint war, als er eingetippt wurde, der aber durchaus interessant werden könnte. Wie verdient man Geld mit einem Computer?
Da habe ich ja gerade ein passendes Zitat. Because that's where the money is. Das hat der berühmte Bankfolger Willi Sitton gesagt. Insofern ist es im Prinzip beantwortbar.
Das ist aber durchaus eine Sendung, dass man mal darüber redet. Das tun ja viele Leute so, als ob im Internet nur ein Riesenmarkt zu holen ist. Es versuchen auch einige und alle müssen online sein. Eigentlich hat man den Eindruck, dass da eher so Geschäfte über so Kompensationsverfahren hin und her geschoben werden, Links ausgetauscht und so.
Ja, im Wesentlichen sind die die Sexindustrie im Internet.
Ja gut.
Aber das Internet verkauft man derzeit vor allem Firmen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die wirklich verdienen. Das wäre durchaus interessant, mal mit Leuten zu reden, die so was machen, ob die wirklich verdienen. Ich glaube, die tun immer so, als ob sie verdienen. Oder man hat den Eindruck...
Ich meine, an der Diskussion selbst verdienen in erster Linie die konventionellen alten Medien. Also diese ganzen Internetbücher bis zum abwinken, Zeitschriften, Fernsehprogramme, Radiosendungen.
Aber Radiosendungen gibt es ja nicht so viele. Aber zum Beispiel Bücher, wenn du in Buchabteilungen gehst, ist das unglaublich. So schalte ich meinen Computer an, auf nur 300 Seiten.
Auf der Internetworld saß auch jemand vom Deutschlandfunk neben mir. Ach so, Internetworld. Derzeit läuft ja die Internetworld-Messe auf dem Messegelände in Berlin. Ich kann euch da getrost von Abraten dahin zugehen. Die wollen doch tatsächlich 50 Mark haben. Dafür kriegt ihr dann erklärt, bei welcher Firma ihr eure Homepage machen lassen könnt. Also wirklich nichts zu holen. Dort spart euch euer Geld. Oder wenn ihr trotzdem hin wollt, gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit zu behaupten, du hättest dich über das Internet angemeldet. Dann redet ihr einfach so lang und marschiert da einfach rein.
Oder ihr marschiert da einfach rein.
Aber es ist wirklich nichts zu holen. Wo soll das alles hinführen?
Ach, ich weiß auch nicht. Du musst mich gerade von Zen belehren lassen, dass man in Zen spricht. Ich liess mal ein paar Bücher. Ich liess mal ein paar Bücher. Zen ist voll okay. Man kann Zen sagen, aber man kann auch Zen sagen. Genau, hier pöbeln mit den Chattern, ohne selber zu chatten. Gut, Internetworld wurde abgeraten, wobei man dann zusagen musste, ich will da überhaupt keine Werbung für machen, aber die 50 Mark Eintritt hätte man sich sparen können, weil überall lagen diese Zettel rum von wegen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich dich umsonst registrieren lassen konnte.
Ich bin froh, wenn du überhaupt jemanden konntest. Das ist aber auch ein Elend mit den Messegeländen hier in Berlin, da läuft für dich fast überhaupt nichts Interessantes.
Da war neulich eine sehr interessante Mineralienmesse.
Mineralöl.
Zumindest für unser Bereich, meinte ich.
Warst du da, Andreas?
Mineralöl, Mineralien, Steine.
Ach, Mineralien.
Ja.
Das ist ja super interessant, erzähl doch mal ein bisschen davon.
Na ja, im Wesentlichen waren da drei Sorten Leute. Da waren drei Sorten Leute, die Esoteriker, die Mineralogen und die Leute, die schicke Steine sammeln.
Hat das Schnittmengen?
Nein.
Keine Schnittmengen.
Du meinst, die Esoteriker haben sich die Steine gegen die Schläfe gerieben, die Mineralisten haben sie gegen die Sonne gehalten, um zu gucken, wie die Solstanz ist? Kleine Etiketten dran geklebt. Zu welchen gehörst du, wenn du da warst?
Tja, ich wollte mir meine Mineralogenmesser angucken.
Ach echt?
Also sozusagen aus soziologischem Interesse.
Genau.
Und hast du da was mit rausgetragen?
Steine.
Mehr Mods von euch.
Das ist jetzt die Diskette.
Das ist die Diskette, ja.
Das ist die Datei, die überlebt hat. Mein Gott, das hat gedauert bis ich wusste, was eine rare Datei ist. Weißt du, was eine.rar Datei ist? Nee, das ist wieder so ein Archivformat auf dem PC. Da muss man erst mal drauf kommen. Ich musste mir noch ein anrar.exe auf meinen Macintosh runterladen, das Ding auspacken. Das war ein Abenteuer, aber ich hab sie gut gekriegt.
Hat sich ja bis jetzt gelohnt. Das klingt aber extrem klasse, finde ich. Weißt du, ob das aus dem Archiv ist oder was der Typ selber gemacht hat?
Das sieht echt Selfmade aus. Das wüsste ich gerne. Ich hab deine Adresse. Ich hoffe, ich hab den Briefumschlag nicht weggeschmissen. Du könntest mir das andere Pfeil nochmal schicken. Das war nämlich kaputt. Das andere RAR-Pfeil. Vielleicht schickst du es mir das nächste Mal nicht als RAR, sondern als Typ. Okay, es ist ein großes Pfeil. Ich weiß, es muss eingepackt werden.
Lass dich auch dieser Teil mittlerweile mit gängigen Packern gut packen.
Ich hab's nicht verglichen, wie groß vorhin nachher war. Aber es passte immerhin auf die Diskette mit zusammen einem anderen Pfeil. Das ist jetzt schon mega. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall sehr geil.
Ja, Chaosradio geht zu Ende. Ich bedanke mich bei allen, die angerufen haben, bei allen natürlich, die einfach nur zugehört haben, bei allen, die sich in irgendeiner Form beteiligt haben oder einfach nur mit Interesse dabei waren. Und natürlich ganz besonders bei allen, die hier im Chat mit rumgeplaudert haben und Witzchen gemacht haben und rumgepöbelt haben, weiter so. Diese Chat-Geschichte, ihr könnt da natürlich jetzt weiterarbeiten, aber morgen früh um neun oder so, wird wahrscheinlich alles zusammenbrechen, weil Lutz dann weiter daran programmiert. Das ist wie gesagt eine Beta-Version, das wird nicht so bleiben, da wird es auch noch mehr Bereiche geben und das wird alles erweitert werden, damit es dann in Zukunft einfach einen Fritz-Bereich gibt. Dann wird es auch so eine Art Fritz-Newsgroup geben. Es haben viele Leute gefragt, warum nicht IRC? Das ist ganz einfach, weil viele Leute, die sich im Internet noch nicht so lange bewegen, einfach nur ihren Browser kennen, denen sagt IRC nichts, denen sind vielleicht die Befehle zu kompliziert. Und ich glaube, für Sendungen, wo es schnell gehen soll, wo es einfach sein soll, sind Web-Chat-Geschichten dann okay. Aber mal gucken, wie wir das alles in Zukunft einbinden werden, natürlich auch in anderen Blue Moons, nicht nur in dem hier. Denn wir werden natürlich weiter versuchen, mehrere Medien hier miteinander zu verkoppeln und immer mehr Möglichkeiten für euch zu bieten, da einzugreifen.
So, das war's?
Das war's, ne? Ich sag schon mal Tschüss, ich heiße John.
Tschüss.
Wieder schön.
Nächstes Mal gibt's Wares.
Das ist schon nächstes Mal.
Erwähnen uns nicht zwischendurch der Himmel auf dem Kopffeld oder ähnliches.
Kannst du mir noch mal diese Adressen für den News Server geben? Es sind echte Trader aus der Traderszene anwesend und werden kein Detail auslassen, wenn ihr schon immer zu wenig Software auf eurem Computer hattet. Tschüss.